你好，我是余欣烈。欢迎收听八八屋。
你好，这期节目是理想i29 Libis上市点评。
我们先从发布会的观感聊起。
大家体感整场发布会没有什么让人上头的地方。
而结尾宣布价格是最high的环节。
而最能get到i29 Libis变化的则是老用户、老车主。
他现在很多好确实需要对比，确实需要跟老款对比。
那目前跟老款对比最明显肯定是老款车主。
所以今天试驾的很多客户都是原来的理想i29的，或者是理想其他系列的车主。
确实更多，而且多很多很多。
关于i29 Libis这款车，大家的评价非常直率。
我超级喜欢这个产品，首先。
换句话说，即便是你看i29 Libis也是认为在当地市场上，他也是同志化很严重的一款车。
我认同啊，我认同的，这个我是认同的。
但是确实给我感觉就是哦，50万的车确实就这个质感，好好感。
确实做得挺强的，尤其是外观内饰，很多细节都做得很到位。
但是第二个，他确实没什么突出的点。
或者说他不会突出道说你觉得哇操，我飞这个车不猛。
或者是那种强烈的道说，非常有品牌风格的东西，你感受不出来。
但让我最惊讶的还是肉呆和小康认为i29 Libis给他们带来了很强的情绪价值。
i29 Libis，我觉得i29 Libis这一次能让我觉得有点动心，是因为他也有给了我一些小米预期给不了的情绪价值。
我觉得这是i29 Libis这一次，或者理想整个品牌这一次最牛逼的地方。
在讨论i29 Libis的设计室，关于双色车身和内饰设计风格是否统一，其他三个人都不同意我的观点。
对我来说，双色车身是跟内饰的风格不一致的。
它是更外显的，更给别人来做的。
而它的内饰是内脸的克制的高级，是为自己做的。
这次i29 Libis上市发布的重点，基本上都落到了车上，落到了硬件上。
而关于巨身智能，大家都理解挑战会很大，但对当下也有些失望。
但是我更想看的是巨身智能，就最核心外点巨身智能。
但这次没看到，我不知道什么时候会推出来。
i29从一个家庭旗舰的一个定位，官方的slogan，变成了一个巨身智能旗舰。
它是一个整个公司代表位来方向的一个旗舰产品。
但是它没有能够说服我，它为什么称得上巨身智能旗舰这个title。
这期i29 Libis上市点评，有直率的批评，有认真的夸奖，还有不同观点的争论。
希望你能完整听完，也帮助我们多评论，多转发。
本期主播是肉呆大魔王，孙少君，郑小康和我。
播客内容都是主播们的个人观点，不客观，不公正。
好，让我们开始吧。
今天5月16号晚上，然后我们来聊一聊昨天刚刚上市的理想i29 Libis。
传统官吏吧，大家按顺序介绍一下自己。
大家好，我是车份孙少君。
大家好，我是肉呆。
大家好，我是内心频道的小康。
我不知道为什么这个耳家耳机在我耳朵上如此的奇怪。
OK，咱们挨个来吧，先从发布开始，大家都看发布会了吧。
简单聊一下发布会的观感吧。
现场吧，去讲产品上赛吧，回到了苹果风格的拼盘路播是发布。
常规操作，他们又在发布会之后安排了非常长时间的直播的讲车。
第一波是理想自己带着老汤，然后相关的生命经理，
像蓝一哈特等等，也做了非常长时间的车内的功能讲解。
简单，你们对理想这次发布会的一些观感，
这种形式因为和其他品牌差异很大，
像小鹏未来还在坚持产品技术发布会和最第二次的上市发布会，
这样的一个传统技能。
红魔之行一直是自己的拼盘，加上一字性上市发布。
小米现在也变得比以前规模时间都缩短了一些。
小康先来。
有这样的造型叠带策略在这个背景下，
其实我是比较推崇再来一个技术发布会的。
这个技术发布会会涵盖马合一百。
当然新环OS，就是逻辑上来说这是一个完全体，
然后包括这种正式发布会上，
就515上面讲的完全体的先空底盘以及主动选家。
为什么呢？
因为它的造型变化不是那么大，
所以我需要一个这种单独的技术发布会来进一步强化，
就是它其实变的东西很多很多。
但我不知道发生了什么，
就是最终我们是看到是一个简单俐落的，
实际上试驾活动也是非常干脆的，
如果就是看发布会的朋友们不知道的话，
就是这次试驾也没有所谓的动静，
它就是一次，然后会把所有的东西全部展示掉。
当然理想的试驾就是一贯的就是高质量的时间，
就是说会给你充足的拍摄时间，
然后动静它，你只要你愿意，
你可以你有充分的时间能把它全部都呈现出来。
但是我的意思是它并没有，
它整个宣发节奏就是感觉是一个拳头打出去，
没有再切任何的。
我只是从这个设计的角度，
因为内外式的变化尤其对普通人来说不是那么大，
实际上它的提升，如果两台这摆在一起是非常明显的。
但是如果说路人不好分辨的话，
我觉得是需要一个非常重要的技术发布会。
刚刚还漏了一个，就是除了主动拳架先攻地盘，
马合一般，还有那个新一代真正器，
其实我觉得这台之上换的东西超级多。
对吧，我觉得值得再来一遍，
就是单独的技术发布会，
只是结果是这个一次解决嘛，
然后再说这一次发布会，一次发布会解决，
反正意识到一个问题就是，
苹果公司的管理层它整体相对来说比较问题。
拼盘呢，我觉得就是第一次拼的时候，
包括苹果我觉得也会有这样的问题，
就是生面孔就是生面孔，
还是有一个让大家慢慢接受的过程。
但是如果说来来回回就这么几个人，
我觉得拼盘也OK。
但是这一次Levis的拼盘呢，
拼的和之前的又不是不太一样。
如果说比如说一年一次这种。
重磅产品的发布会假设，
如果是换了人的话，
可能不一样，
就比如说大家已经比较熟悉新阳了，对吧。
但这个车可能跟新阳没有什么关系，
可能是就是蓝银哈特的车，
所以蓝银哈特来讲，
但蓝银哈特其实之前没讲过，
我觉得会有一些这样的影响吧，
包括人事的变动，
这些因素我觉得应该考虑在内，
就我个人而言，
如果是理想从头干到尾的话，
我觉得会更好一些。
当然这个跟跟公司层面有关，
就是说大家是不是觉得老板应该。
负责一小趴而不是从头干到尾。
如果说理想从传播高层的逻辑。
是这样往下推的话，
可能就会有今天这样的结果，对吧。
但是如果说像L9Levis这么一台车，
至少是真诚旗舰吧，
其实我觉得在整个公司层面也算得上是旗舰。
如果是理想从头讲到尾的话，
我觉得会更爽一些对我来说。
我觉得基本就是这样，
包括其实对除了蓝银哈特，
其实基本上全是神面孔，
除了理想之外，
现言其实也是第一次出来。
那你觉得对于这么一款这么多。
强交技术性的更新迭代，
这样发布会讲完的效果怎么样？
我会觉得，
就是说从价格设置上来说，
就最终的，
从预售到最终的价格的这个公布来，
这个角度来看，
其实是很有冲击力的。
但是呢，
整个发布会的节奏是比较，
比较平的，
我觉得，
其实还有一个在我们这个list里面没有，
没有提到就是，
其实有很多的公司是比较走这个线下发布会，
还是走的比较多的。
小朋友啊，未来啊，活梦啊，
其实都会干线下发布会。
理想的话，
这一次也是延续的之前的，
就是比较坚决的走了，
纯线上。
我不知道这个有没有影响，
反正,
如果,
对我这种媒体来说是有影响的。
我自己过去的经验，
这个体会是非常深刻的，
就是,
任何车如果在线上，
我都会更上头，
任何车都是，
当年理想完，
我们在线上，
我们觉得往，
太棒了。
小米书期，
就是你在线上，
不知道为什么，
你整个情绪一直往上演，
往上顶，
然后,
如果你在电脑前，
手机前看的话呢，
不知道为什么，
你又突然冷静客观，
理性了很多很多。
反正这也是一个，
一个方面，
理想是比较坚决的走了，
就是不去做这个线下。
一开始，
其实早期理想是，
当过很多很多线下发布会的，
但是最近几次，
其实都转成纯线上，
但是这些，
我们只是讨论形势，
我觉得产品才是，
才是重点。
来，少君，
聊聊你的发布会的观感。
那天是这样子的，
因为微博官方邀请我做直播嘛，
然后我就当天，
你去两场的直播，
上市发布会，
当时就出了一个，
比较尴尬，
就两场的同时播，
那不然我自己的感受，
就很明显了，就是，
你看,
因为像老鱼在讲，
老鱼那种线上的，
寄阳程度，
线上的欢呼之类的，
就做更直白点，
就是只要是，
老鱼一讲话，
所有人开开心心，
非常爽，
就很简单的道理，
就是大家都，
反馈很好，
大家都觉得，
哇操，好牛逼。
其实,
很多功能，
其实之前都已经知道了，
但是就是在线上，
你就感觉到，
非常的寄阳，
就这么简单，
但是,
我切到理想的画面的时候，
因为两场是同时直播，
相当于同时直播，
然后一下子弹幕就静下来，
呵呵呵，
弹幕就安静下来，
然后搭建两下，
也没什么好凉的。
最后可能最激动的，
就是最后公布价格，
然后连续说，
从55.980万,。
降到了，
就降5万块钱，
然后又，
又给了2万块钱，
现金,
权益,
又给了一个，
1万块钱的特殊，
真话,
确实,
很激动的，
现场确实，
就,
只有这个最后，
这个点炸出来的时候，
所有人才非常激动，
然后,
弹幕瞬间就播起来，
就，这是我那天，
自己在直播的时候，
最明显的感受就是，
其实那场，
就我,
我个人觉得，
第一个是，
理想的发布会，
其实开过太多场，
是这种，
录播形式的，
就导致大家，
对这种苹果风格录播形式，
其实有点麻木了，
如果,
一次两次，
早期开的话，
我记得早期开，
其实效果还是可以的，
因为大家觉得，
哦，还挺吸引，
对,
然后讲的也比较简单，
但是,
新的,
其实我发现，
大家听下去的，
耐心在电路，
我个人觉得，
就是这种，
苹果式的直播，
其实大家耐心在电路，
这个我自己看，
苹果的发布会的时候，
我也有这种感觉，
就是,
实际上你会发现，
很多人也看不下去，
苹果的发布会，
大家还是喜欢去看，
国内,
像雷军，
像于成东，
这种,
现场有激情的，
你,
所以,
这是第一个，
第二个的话，
我个人感觉，
就是,
今年整个，
市场,
尤其旗舰车型太多了，
然后,
旗舰车型太多，
就导致，
大家其实对产品的配置，
相对来说，
有点麻木，
就比如说，
硬件,
你有主动悬架，
它也有，
悬架,
A有B有C有，
然后,
你可以小果撒尿，
它也可以小果撒尿的，
第三家也可以小果撒尿，
就,
所以你看，
在讲功能的时候，
其实用户也麻木，
就你可以说，
哎，我跟它有什么差异，
但是用户，
你听了是，
到底差在哪里呢？
70分,
跟75分,
那对我来说，
没有区别，
所以,
这就是个很尴尬的问题，
就是,
以前可能，
大家就觉得，
当时L系列，
比较爆的原因是，
因为有些东西，
只有你有，
别人没有，
所以你讲起来，
可能大家听起来，
就特别有感觉，
但是说，
所有东西都有的时候，
无聊感会被加深，
而且是很明显的被加深，
所以听完之后，
说,
做的价格确实很震撼，
所有人震撼，
但是,
前面的确实，
那我感觉，
没有没什么激情，
我们不是在批评说，
它到底，
发布会本身做的怎么样，
而是,
确实看比较多长的，
我后面也受不了了，
就是,
因为我能看，
我当时一直在看，
在线人数，
一千回理想，
一千六，一千八，
直接剩下的，
只有,
一千二，一千一，
那我就赶快，
就切回去，
另一场直播，
倒没办法，
对,
OK,
来,
导师,
我先吸口眼，
你看,
稍微有点头疼，
我跟,
那个,
小潘和导军，
就是,
其实,
我就当个元宝，
总结一下，
他俩都画就行，
那对我自己的，
这个,
观感也是这样的，
是,
我是,
那天,
那天在哪个活动，
我忘了，
反正,
我忘了在哪个活动上了，
然后,
再去看的时候，
我再去，
就是,
在活动现场，
因为那个是线下的会，
然后我就抽空去看，
然后呢，就是，
我这里面，
我给大家补充一个，
厂商的一个视角吧，
这个是来自一个，
经常开发布会的这个，
一个厂商，
但是这个呢，
我就不提名字了，
稍微有点敏感，
这个,
这个市场负责人就跟我说，
说,
哎呦,
我们特别特别喜欢，
办线下的会，
说,
为什么？
这个线下会，
你的成本，
不得比线上的要高吗？
这其实，
当时其实没有，
没有高多少，
但是呢，
让大家来，
大家线下，
聊聊天，
那个,
见个面，
这个传播效果，
要好于做线上发布会，
然后,
我说这个，
就是我其实是，
当时我其实，
都媒体嘛，
这是我们工作嘛，
你要是，
这个给我们，
对吧,
就是,
开发布会，
让我们去发，
发新闻，
这是我们的本质工作，
他说,
其实也不是，
说这个线下发布会，
他就会给大家一个，
比较容易，
越聊越，
还围绕我这个，
这个产品去，
聊的这么一个机会，
他说,
你看凭我，
到现在还是开这个，
他从疫情的时候，
一直到现在，
一直开线上的会，
但是,
他即便开线上的会，
他还会花钱，
把他们之前的媒体，
再运过去，
因为那个氛围，
是无可比拟的，
就是,
我在现场，
哎呀,
参加了发布会，
就像小康说的，
我一定会有那种，
剧场效应，
就是,
为什么那些迷散，
那些活动，
宗教和活动，
都是搞一个那个，
人数虽然不多，
我但是，
我也要定期去这么搞，
就是因为那种，
焦虑的氛围，
已经在剧场里面，
只能听我，
只能听我讲完的，
这种感觉，
然后呢，
再去结合，
你接下来，
该去,
要去拍产品，
因为，不光你知道，
用户也知道，
用户希望你得了，
一是第一手资料，
然后用户希望你，
能够给他们，
带来新的，
一些体验的，
这个项目感，
所以呢，
用户就会，
就是有很多博主，
就会,
我知道，
用户喜欢，
这个流量方向，
所以我会在这个，
开门发布会之后，
我会冲向那个，
Demo区,
和产品体验区，
给大家带来，
这个,
第一手的这个体验，
看看这个，
因为我，
我肯定就，
体验过了，
我这么过来，
跟你说的时候，
你肯这个，
也是,
也是有所准备的，
然后第二天，
上午八点，
躲开天下秀的，
这种,
假你的这个时间，
第二天上早上八点，
然后大家一发内容，
用户早起的时候，
去看一下，
这些,
这些东西，
要不换存一下，
路上看，
这是已经形成了这么一个，
比较,
这这个，
不是我，
现在给这个定义，
这个大负责人跟我说，
他说，这样呢，
已经形成了一个，
用户长久以来，
无论是对于手机，
电脑,
气出,
甚至于相机，
它都是，
它都是这么高，
所以就是，
线下发布会的必要性，
在他看来，
就是要比线上，
要好,
所以他们，
除了他们的，
一些小迪带产品，
是开线上发布会，
其他,
全部都是线下，
就是线下去搞，
然后这次，
特别巧，
今天,
因为那个，
我们公司，
还有他们的业务，
今天上午，
被他拷起来，
加班的时候，
他也问我这个问题，
说,
他想不明白，
为什么，
理想,
R9,
Levis,
这个量级的车，
会要做线上，
因为他，
他们的渔情监测系统，
已经我们，
渔情监测系统，
就会发现，
这次发布会，
理想发布会的声量，
还没有老汤哥，
去做一个，
佛称,
来的那个，
什么,
就是,
我们不是说，
这个声量不高，
而是说，
它的这个，
咱们按照这个比例，
去比,
它肯定，
还是发布会的比，
那个声量更高，
但是,
你按照传播比例，
来说,
这个比例，
其实差不多了，
为什么呢，
是因为，
刚邵俊说，
问戒,
小狗撒尿，
你也小狗撒尿，
所以,
大家都会，
拿这个去比，
除了这个之外呢，
你的电容，
你的电容门呢，
电开门呢，
就是因为可能，
这个分件M9，
它的产品重点，
不在这个地方呢，
你会发现，
理想R9Livis,。
这个传播的这个，
纵深,
也没有那么，
也没有那么深，
所以就是，
它有个戒事，
但是理想R9Livis，
它应该是别人戒它的事，
它不应该戒别人的事，
所以我觉得这个对，
发布会是有一个，
这个对这件事情，
传播的这个力度，
和广度，
是有影响，
那如果我们，
直接从数据上看的话，
这次发布会，
也只能说是用，
反响评评，
这么一个形容词去，
我们去监测用户的数据也是，
用户就会，
待会儿看着手机，
真的是最后，
说哇操，
真有笔，
就是,
价格公布的时候，
因为大家都有五十五万多，
那个用户还讨论说，
那Mega怎么卖啊，
他就说，
啊这个钱，
这个钱，老用户，
又说老用户，
啊这个，
直接解面，
一万块钱，
哇，就用户就，
觉得哇塞，
这个厉害，
这个好，
就包括，
我们有这个，
埋伏在他们线下，
在他们线下店，
看着这些人，
看现场也是，
在前面很长的一段，
这个时间，
用户就会觉得，
那些新用户，
对于产品的了解，
那些新面孔，
有理想能生吗？
啊为什么，
隔壁是余成东在那，
哇哇哇讲，
然后雷军在那，
然后讲的都，
快七群老人，
真的六群老人，
在台上就守国门，
哎，你个80后，
怎么感觉，
就像,
气血不足的样子，
就是,
这个是用户，
真的会去反馈的事情，
所以,
就这两点嘛，
我觉得并不是说，
一个,
这个只是一个市场选择，
理想R9,
Leavis呢,。
他整个产品，
的变化，
我觉得，
并不是一场发布会，
可以讲完了，
反而像马和M100，
像他的800福的这个，
绝对保持，
能够保持绝对领先的，
这么一个，
几个技术点嘛，
是要单独，
查开,
去讲，去传播的，
然后在，
这个,
结合R9这个产品，
静态动态去体验，
最后落到这个价格上，
它是一个，
它应该是一个，
更加怎么说，
更加市场化，
更加营销化的，
营销味更重一点，
这么一个行为，
现在就营销味，
稍微点弱了，
不会呀，
无所谓，
卖的好，
什么都是对的，
卖不好，
这些才是问题。
当时发布会结尾，
我以为，
就给我的感觉，
是一下从，
苹果的发布会，
一下切换到了，
小米的发布会，
这个送，
这个直降5万，
然后,
首消其权益，
当时确实，
冲击力很强，
但另一方面，
主要你刚才谈到，
用户一下，
觉得很直，
少军也谈到了，
那如果，
他们对产品的配置，
没有那么理解的话，
就是这个直的感觉，
是怎么来的呢，
它在需要建立在，
他们认可这个配置，
这个产品的，
基础上，
才会觉得直，
当然,
另一方面，
是因为直降5万，
也有很冲击力，
另一个我还要问，
肉带的就是，
这样发布会，
这种形式吧，
它肯定有好的方面，
就对我来说，
可能,
因为,
它整体的变化，
很多是在底层的嘛，
在车的底盘上，
或者芯片上，
它不容易，
更多的去展示出来，
它通过一个，
录播的发布会，
能够制作，
工作的动效，
以及产品本身的质感，
因为,
之前都谈到，
它容易，
让我们在放里头嘛，
看不出来，
在哪儿，
它会把一些内饰的细节，
或者些东西，
放大了，
通过基础手段，
呈现出来，
可能传播效果，
更好一点，
就是理想这么搞，
它肯定有它，
取舍的地方嘛，
那好的一些方面，
是什么呢？
完,
你非得这么问，
我其实，
我没有觉得有，
特别,
不是,
没好的地儿，
就是,
其实是，
你能感受出来，
就是,
这场发布会，
效率之高，
其实刚刚，
从试驾，
哎呀,
就是讲workshops,。
然后静态体现，
然后第二天，
就,
再加上那个科目，
第二天，
你去这个动态试驾，
我觉得这个安排之巧妙，
以及效率之高，
是让人就感觉惊讶的，
然后它那个发布会也是，
我感觉它发布会就是，
向副手者联盟一，
就是你登场的角色贼多，
那怎么办？
它就需要通过一些，
灰械的方式，
或者是一些巧妙的安排，
让整个发布会看起来，
新鲜量，
在新鲜量非常大的时候，
这个基础上，
不会看上去那么疲惫，
我觉得这是最大的好处，
就它没那么疲惫，
但是,
我觉得，
就是要说但是了，
但是之前可能都是废话，
就是说这个但是，
你这个线上发布会，
包括今年，
你会看到很多场上开发发布会，
尤其开发这种线上发布会之后，
它会有大量的切片出来，
就是关于我发布会的，
切片出来，
因为密度太大了，
我没办法，
这个以官方的视角做切片，
那我想问，
也想问问大家，
大家能看到现在理想官方，
有把它，
昨天24 hrs了吧，
有把它的这个，
就是密集的切片，
密集信息的切片放出来，
没有,
马赫M100,
对嘛,
你的八百福底盘，
它现在开始，
就我们现在渔情监测，
我刚刚看了一眼，
就完全陷入了这个舆论站，
就被别人拉扯到那个泥潭里面，
我要跟他比，
这个时候，
你就会非常消耗你的战斗力，
你就,
你作为一个集团军，
别人给你打游击战，
那你这个打起来，
就会，就有点美军在越南，
那个感觉，
就处处撤走，
你也不可能拿这个东西轰炸，
因为这个时候，
已经不像是你，
2022年,
理想R9,
刚发布的那个时候了，
那个时候，
就是就是人物我有，
我想怎么捏你们，
就怎么捏你们，
一个空旋，
一个负面的，
那个舆论关于空旋，
负面的一个渔情，
它都能转化成一个，
哎，这是国展的，
我独有，
你不信你开一开，
那现在呢，
现在感觉就是，
它催单是够了，
但是催用回去体验呢，
觉得还是远远不够的，
就这个吸引力是要持续的，
它没有把握好
线上发布会的那个事呢，
甚至今天小红书，
还有这个关于它OS 8.5的这个，
更新的这么一个，
小的一个声量上来，
我觉得就是不应该的，
你的耳朵久了，
为什么一个突然的版本更新，
都能抢到一个小舆论的一个，
就是那个信息，
信息发布的这么一个小热点，
我觉得这是不应该的，
那除了这个，
我觉得都是，
对于线上发布会，
我觉得至少在国内啊，
做线上发布会做的好的，
理想是属于所谓的，
至少能比，
国内的手机厂商都要是，
都要质量啊，
和它观点都要好几个档次的，
这么一个存在。
简单聊聊大家，
这函品的感受，
因为什么聊这个，
大家应该基本上都接触过真人产品啊，
这个产品其实，
复杂度，
以及它更新的东西，
确实,
对我来说，
确实需要有很多的学习成本吧，
去理解这个东西，
就是大家包括对内饰，
这次谈到的所谓，
说话的松弛的这种体感，
包括它双色车身的体感，
因为我们看发布会，
大多数人听众吧，
都是这种画面嘛，视频嘛，
大家真实感受怎么样，
包括开起来，
它这个卖点，
亲身的感受体感如何，
来，小康。
我没开车，
我看车了，
车我看过了，
我没开，
我觉得现在，
就好的不好的都说一遍吧，
好的层面，
我超级喜欢这个产品，
首先,
两个层面的，
我记得我们之前说过了，
共没有听之前直播的朋友们，
我再多说一遍，
第一个层面的喜欢是，
我确实相对来说，
更加认可这种，
扫击是多，
这种设计方式，
我觉得它不登，
当然你可以有另外的解读角度，
就是说，
我认为在所有的，
头部的这几个久系旗舰里面，
L9Livis,。
其实加上了双拼，
我依然觉得它是最不伤我的，
我确实不太喜欢那种，
过分伤我的车，
我觉得它会让，
让我开着这台车，
有一种区隔感，
有一种隔离感，
相比于，
就跟我身边的朋友们也好，
或者是，
公司层面的这个，
合作伙伴，
之类的也好，
我觉得这个车，
整个内外式的，
升级幅度都巨大，
相比于老款，
并且,
我觉得它放在，
今天的一众久系当中，
我觉得它也不输，
它有充足的竞争力，
这儿的充足的竞争力，
不仅关乎于它，
完整的这个配置层面，
比如说，
我们主动宣家，
所有这些新一代正成级，
这些不在啰嗦，
就不仅关乎于配置层面，
产品力层面，
我的意思是，
内外式的品位，
它的格调，
这个伪度，
我认为它完全，
能够和任何一台，
久系来PK，
这是我喜欢它的，
第一层，
第一重喜欢，
第二重喜欢，
就是理想自己在，
和大家那次，
采访里面说到，
就是说，
专注运护体验，
并且敢于冒险，
这个我也，
比较喜欢，
那么在这台车上呢，
其实你，
明显还是能看到，
一些些的，
动作的大道，
比如说，
字眼码和100芯片，
这个码和100芯片呢，
走数据流架，
这绝对是一种冒险，
如果说，
字眼芯片，
字眼支架芯片，
本身在今天这个，
遍地字眼芯片，
已经不显得，
是一种，
敢于冒险的行为的话，
那我觉得，
数据流，
数据流这个一定是，
再一个，
比如说，
UWV芯片,
用UWV芯片，
去干掉所有的，
淘身波雷达，
去获得一个，
更好的视觉观感，
然后,
以及获得一个，
号称,
更好的，
近距离，
感知体验，
这个因为，
我觉得，
我们肯定要，
在现实的用车场景里面，
全方位的，
体验完了，
才能得出结论，
它是不是实际的，
体验也更好，
因为不能光听理想说，
是对吧，
就是UWV的，
经常感知，
要比超声波感知，
体验更好，
并且,
你让整个车声顿干净，
就观感也更好，
那肯定是双眼，
那简直非常好，
全方位跟您有完了，
我的意思是，
类似于，
一些这样的冒险，
包括车内，
我不知道大家，
有没有关注，
一些产品体验，
比如说，
前排妈妈在开车，
然后后排小朋友，
想看二排电视，
你既可以，
你当然可以，
语音操控的，
你可以，
就是挑两下，对吧，
那这个其实并不是，
有什么，
类似于iPhone那种，
压力传感器，
或者什么之类的，
它就是，
它是纯粹的，
通过,
仓内视觉去，
实现的，
因为,
你有了8797，
你有了更大的算力，
它,
智利于去用一些，
就是,
更强的去把这个多摩泰，
感知,
和,
交互去，
去做起来，
去,
去尝试，
做一些这样的努力，
我觉得他们肯定还是，
对得上这个，
感遇冒险的，
这个策略，
OK,
所以,
所有事情都说完了，
就是好的地方都说完了，
那么,
没那么好的地方，
我们开始讲，
我说的所有东西，
都是,
都是仅限于，
试驾车，
或者是，
我们车展，
提前看到的那两台车，
因为我不知道，
亮产车，
会不会发生改变，
那么,
这台车，
我觉得有一些，
瑕疵的地方，
一个是，
侧面,
为了追求极致的，
可能是，
极致的这个，
体验,
其实它是没有，
埋,
侧面,
也是没有埋那个，
侧门雷达的，
所以说，
它是用侧面的激光，
去识别，
拉开侧门，
如果有干涉的话，
我就开，
开幅度小一些，
开一小半，
但是现在呢，
眼下有一个，
比较明显的问题呢，
就是,
侧面的那个，
小激光，
它是在，
前椅子吧，
那个位置，
所以,
如果你把前门，
已经打开了，
那后排门，
它就没有办法，
如果说，
是同一个，
家庭成员，
我觉得这也很普遍，
就是,
比如说小朋友，
有时候，
他可能做前排，
有时候做后排，
去给他的体验，
是割裂的，
因为你发现，
这台,
这个门，
有时候很聪明，
有时候没有那么聪明，
会有这样的问题，
我当然知道，
这个技术原理，
是什么，
就是前门，
如果挡了的话，
前椅子板的那个，
侧向激光，
它感知不到后，
它看不到后，
它看不了那么远了，
所以它没有办法解决，
理解这么高深的东西，
你就是没有，
目前你还没有把它解决好，
这是第一个，
第二个是，
那时候我虽然非常喜欢，
但是呢，
氛围的亮度很低，
我们当时，
当时感知到的就是，
其实亮度调到最大，
依然,
不太明显，
给我的感觉，
就是这种不太明显，
超越了我对，
我不觉得，
就是一个极减的车，
内部就需要一个，
亮度不那么高，
最高亮度，
不那么高的氛围灯，
这是我，
我对这个车介意的地方，
然后还有一些小的问题，
也是值得探讨的吧，
就比如说二排的，
首先你有四把零重力，
对吧,
你二排是可以完全躺倒的，
如果你二排可以完全躺倒，
并且你为了，
甚至为了，
小朋友能够直接，
探导它，
能够触控它，
做了滑，
就是神奇屏，
可以前后移动的神奇屏，
我觉得他们是，
为这种做以前后移动，
或者是躺姿，
去做了一些考虑的，那么，
它后排的控制屏，
是不能拿下来，
是一个类似于，
特斯拉或者乐道那样的，
是固定的，
但是这个行业里面，
比如说极客9X，
或者是文件M9，
大家都做了很多这种，
像一个小手机一样，
你只可以直接拿下来，
我觉得它唯一，
它很重要的场景嘛，
就是你完全以零重力，
躺在上面，
然后你拿一个遥控器，
你控制所有的东西，
当然我知道，
就是我们理想的车主，
大家都是理想的车主，
我们都知道，
理想提供的解决方案，
就是遥控器APP，
或者你可以用理想汽车的遥控，
去做这个事情，
但是这里面有一个问题，
就是你得让每一个，
要控制这个二排屏的，
大家都有这么一对理想遥控的APP，
或者是理想汽车的APP，
或者说你后排控制屏，
做都做了，
反正我的立场在这，
我的立场就是，
你做都做了，
为什么不能把它做成可移动的，
我不觉得这里边的成本差异，
是多么夸张的，
然后前排我又想到一个，
就是那个，
首先它有一个，
前后顺序的调换，
就是把杯架，
往前,
把无线充往后，
这是一个毫无疑问，
我认为是99%的人，
都公认的优化的设计，
就是现在比之前更好了，
OK，1%已经出现了，
一会儿让1%说话，
我们先说就是，
就是逻辑很简单，对吧，
我不知道那1%怎么想的，
逻辑很简单，
就是因为这个杯子，
如果放在这儿的话，
你要取放手机，
大家很，
就是你尤其在城市里，
开车很常见，
一到红利根你就要拿起手机来看一眼，
可能什么事也没发生，
你就是习惯性的刷了一下微博，
但是如果有一个很大的杯子的话，
它就一直干涉，
然后你，
你这样顺序一换就没有这个问题了，
然后呢，
理想为了把它静态的，
一致性做得更好的话，
它架了一个盖板，
这也是很常见的说法，
其实22万的特斯拉Model 3，
如果你愿意的话，
你可以把它的，
你可以用盖板，
把它的杯架，
和它的除隔，
所有东西完全封死，
看起来就是极其干净的，
但是理想那个是全手动的，
我不同意，
就是说，
你要把那个杯架露出来的话，
你一推，
它停了，
你再推，
它又停了，
你一直推到里面，
然后你下意识的反应是，
ok，推它是要手动的，
但是,
它可能里面有一个弹簧机构，
然后你往里一按，
所有的车都是这样，
成本低一点的解决方案，
所有车都是这样，
你往里面一按，
然后它就自动回弹，
就关上了，
没有,
你按一下，
没有反应，
你要把它拉出来，
55000的L9Levis,。
我不理解，
我觉得这非常不合适，
就是我这个人，
就是对于很多细节的理念，
和很多的车主们还不一样，
比如说方向盘上去掉的那个小的，
续航家驾驶模式的，
屏幕,
我就非常双手鼓掌欢迎，
因为我觉得那东西，
我开了很久，
大家把我都觉得超级积累，
并且,
就是有很多用户，
就是它超级反对这个，
就是说你给我一个，
超变节的交互控制入口没了，
我强力反对，
你为什么要把这个拿掉？
我就反驳理由也很简单，
尤其像我们这种，
换子车开，
如果你觉得媒体这种，
换子车开的太离谱的话，
我觉得家里不止一台车的，
就是双车用户也很多，
就是大家家里只要有大亭的车，
所有人的续航，
其实都会在车机上，
理想当时的问题是，
你要看续航，
要看那个控制品，
车机上找不到，
然后驾驶模式它也会，
减掉,
为了突现，
就是为了这个分布菜单，
我个人会认为，
如果对于双车，
它也是更有好了，
这个把，
转向柱上的小屏，
拿掉以后，
因为,
你不需要再去思考了，
你下一次的，
就直接找中共上的，
大部分时候，
这是在最上面的一条蓝里面，
它一定会把你的续航放在那，
我个人认为，
这是一个显著更优的，
对，它是一个明显的优化，
而且我从来也不觉得，
然后很多人又开始喷了，
说你控制品没了以后，
哦，50万的车，
连一表盘都不给，
我从来压根，
我真不觉得，
就是一有一表盘，
高人一等，
没一表盘，
哦，就怎么了，
尤其考虑到我们国产，
当然这个某种程度上，
也是二二款理想L，
就开始推动的，
我们国产的HOD，
做的如此的丰富，
行车信息显示如此丰富，
就是你在玩对你的行车，
影响微乎其微的情况下，
其实我觉得大家不要那么的重形式，
就他首先有没有给你带了好的体验，
我觉得是完全带来了，
是解决了这个问题，
然后其他的整体来说，
我对这台车，
包括他这座椅啊，
这些东西，
我都觉得挺好的，
做的挺好的，
可能,
如果有什么问题，
可能需要更长的时间，
可能才能发现吧，
包括,
其实我认为除空间这个事，
我觉得我们不可避免的，
可能是今天直播的后面部分，
会聊到，
除空间这个事，
我认为理想也做到了，
他能做的机制，
如果你一定要说，
你这个是明显不够的，
我觉得可能是，
相比于其他动力形式，
如果是真诚的话，
我觉得他们已经非常，
我都觉得比较好，
比较认可，
跟俩问题啊，
一个是这款车，
其实大幅度的升级，
还是在底盘系统吧，
或者说电气动系统，
不论是，
增程的5C系统，
还是说他的全线控底盘也好，
独立宣家也好，
但是你在没有开的情况下，
你就这么喜欢一款车，
那更多的是来自于什么呢，
是你对这种，
产品定义的价值观的认可，
还是什么，
你刚才喜欢了很多，
东西是他的精神层面的东西，对吧，
另外你就是在看这款车，
比如说发布会也好，
或者在看这款车的配置的时候，
你作为一个用户的角度，
视角,
你有激众过你的瞬间吗，
某个配置或者功能，
会让你觉得想买这款车，
我接着说完了，
我一定要先接着说完，
因为我就担心大家有这样的误解，
首先我还是要重申一下，
我不觉得我喜欢，
新的L9是纯粹精神层面，
我认为，
纯粹的产品这个维度，
我也非常喜欢这个车，
但是我没有买，
我后面会解释为什么，
第二个问题就是，
你为什么没有开过它，
就是云屏你能喜欢，
果然没提人的嘴脸，
这个问题呢，
我认为是这样，
从i8和i6开始，
这些理想的车，
做得越来越熟，
我觉得它的驾驶性，
真的去做得越来越好，
尽管单踏版还是一言难尽，
就是它OTA之后的单踏版，
我觉得依然做得不够好，
虽然我不明白，
就是这个东西，
为什么这么难，
还是说它其实也不难，
只是优先级低，
或者是分配给，
分配给做这个功能的人，
支援低，
我不知道是什么原因，
但是它单踏版做的没有那么好，
但是就是我存在，
我可以这么讲，
我想问问屏幕前的各位，
或者说是这个叫什么，
就是耳机前的各位，
怎么双枪双伐的空气选家，
满足不了你们吗？
我很想了解这个，
我知道主动选家当然很好，
主动选家车我有开过，
虽然没有开过理想的，
1T9总开过吧，
我知道主动选家是很好，
但是各位，
我开这理想L9在山里面，
去感受测清，
晒到咱先不说，
山里面感受测清的机会，
不是那么多，
大部分时候确确实实，
我承认确实实实，
就是从普通的家里，
开到松江的公司，
然后从松江的公司，
开回普通的家里，
但在上海城市里面，
我确实有点怀疑，
主动选家和双枪空，
选带给我的，
体感上的差异能有多大，
这个是为什么，
我在静台层面，
就挺喜欢这个车的，
其实还有一个余老师，
刚刚是，
我觉得有一篇概权，
就是把它集中到底盘层面，
其实还有一些，
包括真诚器，
这个完全是基于
对于过往理想的信任，
其实说老实话，
二五款的L9，
他们对于NVH，
这些东西的追求都，
我觉得都挺好的，
包括这个，
真诚器的启停时机，
类似这些东西，
或者我也不会抱
特别大的期待，
因为,
老牌真诚做这个事情，
我也不指望，
他能再有一个
巨大的飞跃，
飞跃式的进步，
但是我有一个
巨大期待的试码和一般，
而且,
这儿插开话题，
再聊一个传播上的问题，
去年,
有一个版本叫，
叫ADMAX V14.4,。
今年有了VLA2.1，
然后后面有3了，
又变成VLA了，
他们后面上叫，
马赫不要业了，
我真诚的觉得，
这些东西应该统一，
控制器叫AD5.0，
我觉得这些线，
应该履顺一点，
就不要过分的去消费，
用户的这个，
学习成本，理解成本，
尽量收敛一点，
就不要在这个事情。
想一出是一出，
再一个的话，
就还是回到那个话题上，
我确实对他们的，
之间有严重期待，
我相信那帮哥们，
能搞出来，
虽然,
可能评论器里面，
阴阳怪，
可能要说，
那帮哥们，
是不是已经都走了，
留下来的哥们，
我觉得他们能搞出来，
平台打得也很好，
然后投入也很大，
OK，打动你的，
功能配置冲动？
发布会上，
没有,
这款车，
就是如果你要买的话，
有打动你的，
功能配置吗？
没有,
没有那种，
一击一击重的，
它是要讲没有，
我觉得是，
全方位很综合的，
而且,
就在这个话题，
我觉得我们也可以谈一谈，
比如说，
你买即可9X，
或者是温解M9，
或者是ES8，
因为ES9,
我真心，
我觉得有点下不去，
我觉得它太尊了，
9X也太尊了，
我必须说，
但我觉得这个时代，
我觉得没有一个大缩解，
大家都挺随同车的，
首先是，
至于说，
你会不会被主动选项打动，
在今天有，
三四家同事，
都在提供主动选项的时候，
我觉得这个时候，
也不是很，
不是很现实，
我觉得，
就我个人，
因为我不确定，
后面的机会老师，
会不会突然出来一个，
被某一个东西打动了，
就是,
我这样说，
所以,
我之所以，
不会被某一个东西打动，
我觉得是因为，
所有东西都在通知，
换句话说，
即便是你看L9，
Levis,
也是认为，
当你事实上，
它也是同志化很严重的一款车，
我认同，
我认同的，
这个我是认同的，
但是,
我认为，
就是说在，
今天堆掉的这个时代，
同志化的这个时代，
你依然可以找出来，
一些,
你觉得它是，
做的,
比较克制的，
比较,
契合,
是你想要的，
这么一个，
一种感觉的，
对,
我,
我觉得还是要再说一下，
这台车，
给你的感觉呢，
我觉得还是，
确实,
我说的，
契合的松弛，
是传递出来的，
那么,
我个人开，
哪怕它是一个，
六个座位的车，
我也觉得，
OK,
相反,
我这个人，
确实是，
没有什么，
行政的商务的需求，
我开着它，
去,
去建，去，
去什么，
去香格里拉酒店，
去普通家里城，
这种,
市,
市场,
和都是，
很有限的，
所以,
我不需要它传递，
这些东西，
刚才,
这方面，
确实,
我其实在最后，
价格宣布之后，
我也在，
考虑说，
如果我买的话，
会,
买哪种，
我看,
理想同学，
他们一种，
口径吧，
就说,
很多,
好好品牌，
要买这个，
主动宣价，
花很多钱，
选配,
现在,
只贵五万，
就是,
Ultra,
和Livis,
这个版本嘛，
差得主要，
还是这个，
主动宣价，
选配的，
价差对比的，
而不是说，
真正的，
我的收益对比的，
确实我，
我的感受，
是跟小康类似的，
这我,
可能会，
选择Ultra,。
这对我一个，
城市用户来说，
主动宣价，
它的什么三轮啊，
或者说，
换胎啊，
不足以，
大动我，
我觉得，
那个双枪，
空选,
可能就，
挺好的，
还能省五万块钱，
OK,来,
少君,
聊聊,
你这一款，
我自己也没试过，
这个车，
动态事件，
但是,
静态应该，
我是跟小康一起看的嘛，
对,
那天好像是，
我们两个一起看的，
因为我只看静态，
我就,
三个看法，
第一个，
我觉得五十万的，
豪娃SUV,
其实就是这样，
基本上，
五十万豪娃SUV，
该有的东西，
像主动宣价，
包括内市这个，
因为这个，
原来,
就目前说完听点，
开山,
公车来听点，
就说实话，
现在所有的，
四十万以上的，
其间的SUV的，
质感之类，
最早做的比较好的，
就是,
理想L9,
对,
那很多，
你看到今天，
其实内市外观都在抄它，
确实给我感觉就是，
哦,
五十万的车，
确实就这个质感，
好好感，
那确实做的挺强的，
尤其是外观内市，
很多细节都做得很到位，
但是第二个，
也是跟小康说的，
是一样的，
就是,
它确实没什么突出的点，
或者是说，
它不会，
突出到说，
你觉得，
它不满，
或者是，
或者是那种，
强烈的到说，
非常有品牌风格的东西，
你感受不出来，
比如说，
你可能去看，
未来,
你会先纠结，
换电,
那你就会纠结，
它的一些，
车友,
车友那种活动，
人肯定会提前，
思考的，
就是,
本地的车友群啊，
之类的，
我去了很多地区，
很多用户一听说，
哎,
买未来，
那车友群，
里面会不会拉，
然后就问这些问题，
那换电站，
我家,
换电站一多远，
包含像鸿蒙的，
问GM9,
很多客户会考虑说，
哎，这台车，
是买这台车，
说会跑商务，
那别人就不会问什么了，
一看就是，
哦,
这个车，
确实旗舰，
或者是说，
买,
我就是为了一个A大四五，
那你想这台车，
其实给我感受，
就是,
它的所有东西，
其实对，
用户来说，
它没有很强烈的一个，
辨识度的东西，
更多的是，
哦,
它比较像你们说，
松弛感，
那基本就这样子了，
我自己看过，
实车之后，
你说很核心的卖点，
能展示的，
我个人，
其实,
次次去看，
我非常希望能看到，
巨声智能，
就是,
他们一直在强调巨声智能，
但是我，
我现在有点分不清，
什么是巨声智能，
我,
我帮你们说，
我现在真的，
我帮他说，
这个后维尔的，
我其实，
早期静态体验的时候，
我非常想在这次发布会，
他们梦聊聊，
什么是巨声智能，
我非常希望他聊聊，
因为我发布会直播，
我的圈圈在看嘛，
我在直播也在看，
我真的想看，
巨声智能是什么，
我觉得它硬件，
我想说，
50万级别，
就是要应该这样子，
它确实做到，
应有的豪华感，
跟松弛感，
甚至那种，
设计很自然的风格，
它的外观确实，
说实话，
最近几个车的感觉，
换带,
都没有它自然，
那种细节做到，
这么优雅，
但是我更想看的是，
巨声智能，
就最和线外点，
但这次没看到，
我不知道什么时候，
会推出来，
所以就导致我，
看的时候，
我特别别扭，
就是我就想，
等它巨声智能出来，
但又感觉，
前面我不怎么想看，
那等了半天之后，
就公布价格，
就有一种，
很奇怪的感觉，
等一等，
我觉得，
我还是比较关心，
它那个，
提出巨声智能，
就跟,
小朋友，
小朋友一直在说，
自己AI做，
AI第一款，
AI什么,
我每天看，
我就想说，
那你们告诉我，
你AI到底AI什么，
这样,
你到底，
经常大部分，
现在开玩笑说，
这个你也是AI，
那个也是AI，
感觉你什么，
八步的前面，
加一个AI，
所以如何如何，
但是它确实在，
鱼那座舱，
因为我觉得，
它AI的门槛，
比较低，
它说我这个，
只要能在鱼，
控制,
剥历之类的，
我觉得也可以接受，
但,
巨声智能，
我觉得，
这个词，
词太高级，
我现在真的想看一看，
到底是啥东西，
非常同意啊，
巨声智能这块，
咱们后面，
专门有一趴来谈，
这个确实是，
非常关注，
以及,
我自己，
有点失望的地方，
来,
肉呆,
聊了你对车的感受吧，
也开了，
也做了，
刚才你的1%，
你反对的地方，
我发现，
就是,
咱们几个，
在理想拉黑了，
还是你们拉黑理想啊？
我一直，
啊,
那就活该，
我都不知道啊，
你看,
我跟小康，
还是你有排名啊，
你看,
我们两个都没有，
就你有，
排名拉满了，
我先回答小康那个1%，
我就是那个1，
是为什么，
因为我在试驾课，
我就发现，
我刚才也是，
我跟小康，
小康想的一模一样，
哎呀，我，
你们终于，
把他放在这儿了，
顾头不固定，
我把手机放在那儿，
充电之后，
过了一会儿，
我的手机过热警告了，
我先说不是iPhone，
就直接过热警告了，
为什么？
是因为那个，
以前,
他躲在阴影里面，
现在,
他是太阳直射，
你但凡早起，
你通勤，
那玩必须100%照你，
你就算下班，
下班你也赢着夕阳，
像咱那种牛马，
家庭的这个，
主心牛马，
就是一定会烫，
主人马也会烫，
所以这个问题，
就是,
我个人感觉就是，
他,
这个,
后来当时，
我就试了一下，
那个空调出风口，
要么你让他吹手机，
哎,
你要么让他吹你，
你二选一，
但是那个，
现在已经换成那个，
电子,
传那个电子了嘛，
那个,
我觉得，
哎,
怎么说啊，
就反正，
我个人觉得，
这个改变呢，
其实不太好，
接着这个说，
我,
不是说不太好，
而说可能没想明白，
我就演了这个小细节说，
就是我对，
R9 Lilith,。
整体,
就是,
它是我这么长时间以来，
唯一个，
有点,
动心说，
哎,
要不要把Mega，
先换成它，
那么一个，
毕竟Mega开这么多年了，
就这么一辆车，
原就因为，
它太好看了，
好看的不像，
理想做的车，
我,
当时我体验说，
我都觉得，
哇操,
你们得，
你们是把理想捆起来，
就是欧大的几天，
它怎么可能同意，
这种方案呢，
这么好开的方案，
它一定是，
朝着那种运动感呢，
宝马,
那个X5,
或者那个，
那个级别去，
去调整，
这个太好看，
我到年纪了，
理想终于知道，
我需要开这种的车了，
但是,
整体却确实，
我还说整体上，
我觉得这是一个非常，
让我感到有些意外的车，
有些开起来，
如果从看起来，
看上去，
和坐上去，
开上去，
我觉得至少，
它在坐上去，
和开上去，
这两件事上，
做得非常好，
但是看上去，
我这个要打一个份号，
为什么？
一个是刚刚小康说的那个，
他前面那个，
推的那个盖板，
我不知道这个最终版啊，
我必须，
我外国费这句话负责，
那个推动的感觉，
极其廉价，
这个现场，
我也跟他们说了，
就是那个阻尼感，
完全没有做，
这是第一个地方，
第二个地方呢，
是他增加了两个，
这个后边的那个化妆镜，
这个是之前，
我们调研的时候说，
那个确实，
因为有有宝妈，
他就就受制到，
受到那个看孩子，
这种需求，
他必须要做第二排，
但做第二排，
他又整理移容的这个，
不是不是那个，
就是整理这个，
移容一表的这个需求，
但是,
他没有做那种，
分层就是那种，
也没有做阻尼，
所以他，
他给人，
我得必须找个什么东西，
我给他给演示一下，
正常来说，
你看就像这个，
这个盖板，
就像这个地方一样，
他正常是趴西住了，
对不对，
你把他打开的时候，
他是,
他是晃的，
就是,
他是这么一个感觉，
那个化妆镜，
就是你在形式的图中，
你说他有灯光，
他有灯光，
他有色温，
你可以调整他亮度，
你可以调色温，
但是,
你怎能看这么一个东西，
就是这样的，
你不觉得变的吗，
就是,
当然后来他们跟我说，
这个肯定是要调的，
但是,
我就觉得，
就是他有一些地方，
可能就透露这种感觉，
就包括他的车门开启方式，
我估论着，
也是因为，
就是让我们去体验的，
这个版本，
是因为马赫安一百，
这个芯片，
他们要重新做适配，
其实难度，
我这边，
这这里要，
要跟大家说一下，
就是,
可能就是耳机旁的，
这个朋友说一下，
重新适配，
一款新的芯片的难度，
是超级大的，
你无论是说，
夸围,
苹果,
甚至包括咱们的未来，
他们切换了自己的，
这个芯片平台上，
尤其是他，
还不是以前，
冯诺依曼那个架构，
有很多东西，
你要移植过来，
和重做，
比重做都难，
这个东西，
他能堆上，
现在这个，
这个形态，
能让你感觉，
功能没有，
没有少多少，
就已经，
我觉得就是，
理想真的是，
这个团队，
还挺牛逼的，
加上这么动荡的人员变化，
这么动荡的组织构价变化，
在这个技术上，
我觉得，
这个确实是他们，
值得点赞的地方，
但是这个质感，
实际上我真的是有点，
我在现场没有看见老汤哥，
我一直看见老汤哥，
一定会问他，
为什么，
就是你，
你为什么要，
就是这些，
所有的，
我是说所有的，
几乎他的这个，
带阻尼，
需要有阻尼感的地方，
他做的都是有点，
不是那么好的，
包括,
在现场，
这个是我知道，
就是,
我在网络的一个手，
就是我在现场发现，
他那个电动门，
你按,
你按上面那个按钮，
方便方便，
哎，你按这个，
旁边车门上按钮，
方便方便，
你用语音方便，
也方便，
你用这个，
这个前面这个，
屏幕你去关，
也方便，
最不方便的是什么，
最不方便的，
就是你的爸妈，
或你的孩子，
不想用它，
或者是，
第一次坐上来的时候，
你需要用手关的时候，
这个门越关越重，
越关越重，
可能两位没有体验，
体验了之后，
你们两位，
肯定会觉得，
这是一个，
怎么可以这样，
别的电动门就是，
你随着最后那一点力，
你要用力关一下的那会儿，
它是有，
会给你一个借力，
那个系统，
带上,
但是,
没做,
但是这个是改了，
我说这些事情是为什么的，
原因就是，
我就想表达一个观点，
就是理想而久，
这个是，
你要看整体，
你要是坐上去，
还有开上去，
这是一辆，
真的是一辆，
豪华SUV,
豪华全程SUV，
或者不加前面所有的，
这些,
这个前面，
这些title,。
一辆50万的SUV，
它必须应该有的样子，
它服于家庭，
服于更广泛的用户，
肯定应该是这样，
但是细节，
就是在内视的这些惊喜感，
以及质感上面，
通过这些，
你摸起来，
或者是你和它交互上，
它能给你带了这种爽快感，
和应该有的一些组织，
那些组织感，
我个人感觉，
理想,
R9Livis在这方面，
还是需要持续不断的去优化，
包括在以后的，
什么其他的R8Livis，
或者Mega设计像，
都需要去不断的改进的地方，
我来说一下，
门虽然有点重，
但是,
肉台刚刚的演艺，
我觉得过于，
嘴脸非常丑陋，
我觉得，
肯定是我们这四个，
四个里面，
第二个被拉黑的，
不该一起去死吧，
一起被拉黑吧，
然后我觉得，
我们那天在聊，
在公司里面，
聊Livis的一些，
产品细节的问题，
就像肉台刚刚如此，
如属夹针的那种，
聊法一样的去聊的时候，
我们就有聊回了R9L，
为什么当时就是，
你感觉这个车，
完全无敌完美，
就是Livis相比，
R2款初代，
提升这么大，
但是大家意见这么多，
我觉得可能，
所有的，
车都会有这个，
所处阶段的，
外部环境的不同，
今天市面上的酒戏，
我这不是为你想开拓，
大家可以想一想，
我说的是否有理，
今天市面上的酒戏，
每一台其实都是能找出，
各种各样的问题的，
因为,
你所有的车都有，
你发挥的不够好的地方，
和你发挥的非常好的地方，
所以今天，
今天Livis,。
他面临的最大的一个，
一个变化，
就是外部环境变，
其实你能马上，
找出来外面，
做得比你好的，
方案比你好的，
甚至于要我举个例子，
比如说，
浙阳连，
新闻节M9的浙阳连，
我觉得到了，
完全巅峰的水平，
实体浙阳连，
那个实体浙阳连，
升起来以后，
感觉就是，
就是你，
你就会疑惑，
为什么还有需要一个，
可变的这个，
可变色柏林，
没有任何意义，
你感觉，
但当然他也提供了，
给我感觉是这样，
那个远在云南的朋友，
先收一下，
然后你如果比，
比Livis,
你就会发现，
我觉得他就，
他就做的，
没有到M9那个地步，
可变色柏林本身也是，
如果你去看的话，
今天市面上，
最佳方案，
显然是未来ES9，
但是,
对,
我觉得就是说，
我们之所以能找出来，
Livis的这么多问题，
我觉得只是因为，
今天他是主角，
然后今天外部环境，
巨变了，
就是如果你站在ES9的，
角度来去，
今天主角是ES9的话，
我们再去聊，
你同样也能找出来，
ES9做的,
超级牛的地方，
以及ES9,
相比市面上，
他做的不够好的地方，
我觉得是可以找得出来的，
核心设定是，
今天市面上有四五台酒戏，
再一个就是，
关于刚刚那个，
有没有你，
一下击中你的地方，
我觉得我刚刚，
可能电入媒体，
人设,
就是说，
因为我肯定是不觉得，
就说,
哇,
我买一台温解M9，
因为这东西，
这家就是，
但是如果你把自己，
还原到普通用户的话，
其实你会发现，
今天,
你想主推的，
巨参智能，
这个东西没有打出去，
当然这是后面的问题，
就是巨参智能，
本身究竟是什么，
这是后面，
我们要讨论的问题，
但是他肯定没有，
没有成为，
Evis的杀手剪，
然后成为，
能够促进用户下单的，
这么一个东西，
这肯定今天没有实现，
但是,
无论是M9的支架，
或者是科技吧，
更广泛意义的科技，
因为M9除了支架以外，
也特别喜欢讲，
这种像素搭灯，
什么之类的，对吧，
无论是M9的华为的科技，
还是未来的换点，
我认为这，
都还是有点这种，
独本密集的感觉，
其他家是有点成立的，
但是,
今天Evis,
我觉得是要虚时间，
我先补充一下，
首先呢，
我还是要批评，
郑小航同学，
你这个，
就是还是你这个说的，
还是有点媒体时间，
就我觉得，
就是你肯定，
每个产品，
它都有不足，
但是你要说，
这个,
对于理想R9，
例子来说，
其实是因为我觉得，
它有了，
它就应该做得更好，
因为R9,
理想R9,
我跟大家说一个，
说一个点，
理想R9,
2022年的那个，
第一款R9的时候，
它,
支持那个，
视频输入的那个点，
它,
当时,
做的其实，
并不怎么好，
为什么，
是因为它挑线，
视频传输协议，
是比较落后的，
但是呢，
为什么，
当时大家都觉得，
它没问题，
并且,
它愿意去讲，
很重要的一个原因，
是,
它使用起来，
不会那么复杂，
它减少的使用的复杂性，
它甚至比你家，
连你家电视机，
可能都要，
都要简单一点，
哎,
我觉得这个，
就叫一个完整，
并且,
它的商城，
上了那根线，
所以这个叫，
完整解决方案，
我是觉得，
现在,
理想R9,
不明不好，
而说,
它可能真的是有点，
可能再去调试这个东西，
留给它时间不多，
但是,
无论多，
还是少，
这不应该是一个理由，
它应该提供更加，
完整的解决方案，
你提供了，
但是感受不好，
那用户，
那可能咱们不支撑的，
我觉得，
用户,
肯定它看到这一点的时候，
这肯定会成为一个，
就是叫D-Tractor,。
这是敌会者的，
这么一个，
引化的一个点，
但是我对理想R9，
Livis,
觉得,
我觉得个人觉得，
因为我确实是，
在犹豫说，
哎,
我甚至有点动了，
说小米预期化了，
那可能，
这个不行，
就换成，
再换成R9Livis，
但确实是，
因为两个大车，
确实没有什么太大必要，
所以,
这个我觉得，
还是现在，
还在犹豫，
我现在还在犹豫，
但是,
预期也有5米，
你真的，
你那只是一个大车，
一个超大车，
预期是怎么预期，
对,
就是一个超大车，
对R9Livis,。
来说,
对于这个预期，
它就是一个全尺寸的，
就位了，
并且,
预期能提供的情绪价值，
R9Livis,。
提供不了，
哎,
我觉得R9Livis，
这一次呢，
能让我觉得，
有点动心，
是因为，
它也有，
给了我一些，
小米预期，
给不了的情绪价值，
我觉得，
这是R9Livis,。
这一次，
或者理想整个品牌，
最牛逼的地方，
就是它，
终于明白，
真的不是说，
一些概念性的东西，
甚至,
我觉得，
什么叫，
理想唯一一款，
真正意义上，
把肉埋在饭里的，
饭还香的这么一款，
产品,
就是理想R9Livis，
大家去试了，
就是,
咱那个听众朋友们，
去试了就知道了，
不,
它不像i8，
我看起来是好好，
但是,
你看,
哎,
这个也是旧的，
那个也是旧的，
啊,
样子吧，
也说,
说不上来，
它不是那种，
这个说服力，
就实现上是，
一点一点，
在网上见了，
我觉得，
理想R9Livis,。
就是做好的家法，
它在家法上做的，
不像以前那么克制，
它做出来，
至少,
我给你做的样子，
但是,
对于我个人来说，
我其实是，
对于这个细节，
就是,
我还是，
就要发挥，
这种,
小黑子媒体的，
这个基本作用，
就是,
当看到那个东西之后，
我就一直想说，
包括它的那个，
像,
你好嘛，好，
哎,
这个,
这个能型是唯一一款，
不夹屁股的能型，
不夹你肉，
不能说不夹屁股，
大众的，
所有的那个，
灵型的那个，
灵型的那个设计，
都会夹我，
夹我肉，
它不会，
我专门试了，
但是,
旁边,
就是,
我给我的感觉，
当你去深圳保安机场，
你抬头，
看看它那个天花板，
你再去看看，
理想R9Livis,。
你会觉得，
舒服,
变成保安机场省电嘛，
省电,
它省了好多空调费，
但是呢，
就是,
你有没有什么别的解决方，
很期待它下一代，
有没有什么别的解决方，
这是我来看嘛，
那巨生智能的事，
再说巨生智能的，
这是我，
我个人的感受。
练补充最后一个，
就是关于情绪价值，
我觉得肉得把这个，
引出来挺好的，
在我这儿的排序啊，
我认为，
理想史上，
情绪价值排第一的，
肯定是Mega，
因为它的造型，
实在是过于独一活儿了，
我觉得太拉风了。
你买到这个东西，
你就买到一个最酷的，
最克里独显的，
这么一个东西。
但是我认为，
第二就是L9Levis，
而不是I6，
即使I6是，
有异阳千玺，
I6有,
有理想尝试过的，
过去没尝试过的，
这种,
浅黄之类的车期，
我依然觉得，
L9Levis,。
它停在那里，
包括你坐上车上的感觉，
我觉得它的情绪价值是，
非常成功的，
它也许不是你想要那种，
哇,
就是非常脏压，
无爪的，
外陷的，
无成分为灯的豪华，
也许不是那样，
但是它的，
情绪价值都非常好，
而且内外气质非常统一，
在内外气质统一这个点上，
其实我觉得比Mega，
做得更好。
那你说的这个，
形成价值，
究竟是什么呢？
跟肉呆，
肉呆说的，
你们俩说的是一回事吗？
我,
我不知道，
我说的是，
就是你买的这个车，
其实买了你对，
某一种设计风格，
一种格调，
这些东西，
它有点像你选了一个衣服，
穿在身上，
其实你为什么选这件，
而不选另一件，
因为你比较认可，
你比较吃这一套东西，
就这些东西，
在R2款的R9，
它更像一个追求不犯错的东西，
它就是一个水桶，
它没有，
它可能已经把基础的比例，
做在哪儿了，
但是它可能，
更多的时候，
没有很多的细节来体现，
它又高级了一点点，
没有这些东西，
但是这个在Leavis上，
我觉得是非常明显。
所以你的情绪价值，
是设计带来的？
来，肉呆，
你的情绪价值，
什么带来的？
我,
我的情绪价值，
其实我跟小哈想的，
也是设计带来的，
我给大家举个简单例子，
就是,
我对老款的R9，
所有的R9，
对它的感觉就是优于库，
它确实有大市联名款，
它确实在这个合适的价位，
提供了不错的这个质量，
和这个购买的这个过程，
哎,
现在的理想R9，
Leavis变成,。
变成目的了，
就是,
琢磨它的这个设计，
它是变成一个，
可直到完味的事情，
我觉得这个是一个，
就是对于我来说，
可以用这个方式去，
形容它的演变，
甚至我觉得，
可能在最一开始，
大家不知道，
有优异库这个东西，
突然间出来一个，
哦,
这个仓促式的这么一个，
服装品牌，
然后你可以去购买，
质量还不错，
并且价格还挺低，
然后但慢慢，
它演化成什么，
它可能演化成一家了，
它可能演化成一个，
就是像，
这个比较平庸了，
像现在大家，
买衣服，
第一个反应，
不是这个，
这个优异库了，
它现在就变成，
目击了，
就是哎，我能，
你买的每一件东西，
都是值得去，
啊,
琢磨,
值得去，
它甚至很有可能，
会成为一种，
文化的一种，
一种想法，
然后呢，
但是,
它在这个环境下，
就是,
我就稍微我分，
差出来一点点，
它在这个环境下，
面临的是什么，
面临的优异库，
在当年，
它的竞争对手，
其实没有，
啊,
你就,
就是传统中国那些，
森马,
班尼路这些，
它其实能和，
优异库产生，
直接竞争的东西，
外品牌也是，
你会发现，
经常优异库，
开这地方，
会开个ZARA，
就是因为，
它俩不产生，
直接冲突，
就是它俩戏，
是两拨群体，
但是现在是什么，
现在的市场环境变了，
当你想变成，
拇击的时候，
它面对的是，
以这个，
年轻化为主导的，
洛洛拉蒙，
就是像小米，
它提供绝对的，
情绪价值，
提供绝对的，
品牌影响力，
以及圈层影响力，
然后呢，
再一回头，
反正就是分界M9，
像你这种，
比较灯文化的，
这种圈层，
然后你再看看，
未来ES9,
这个AMPO,
它又是代表了，
AMPO这个品牌，
急剧的，
这个专一的，
往这种生活态度，
和生活表来，
上面就，
就这么一个品牌，
所以它面临的，
面临的，
这个竞争的，
这个烈度，
越来越大了，
所以它逼着，
你逼着理想，
必须去做这么一个转变，
我觉得它现在，
这个转变是对的，
提供了一个，
放松的一个环境，
以及不那么灯的，
这么一个设计，
虽然我现在觉得，
我忘了想，
刚刚说它，
它不灯，
但我感觉，
其实也是蛮灯的，
因为,
你们数把博主的钱啊，
该挣的挣完了，
2020年,
那个R9,
是挣你们数把博主，
我还欺着博主的钱，
你现在，
该挣一些，
年龄到了，对吧，
这四年过去了，
你钱也挣到了，
这个,
身份也转变，
孩子也有了，
咱们就来说说吧，
因为理想，
对一款车的设计，
它自己定义是，
毫而不灯，
小康,
刚才那种，
还是比较认可，
少君,
你觉得，
从用户啊，
或者说，
一线啊，
这种反馈，
大家对这款车，
这种造型，
是怎么来判断的呢，
是,
觉得它，
又吸收了，
传统华华的那些特点，
包括,
双侧车身啊，等等，
还是说，
它打到了一个，
理想说的，
毫而不灯，
让你觉得，
让人觉得很认同，
我的感觉就是，
很简洁啊，
就是越来越，
苹果风啊，
但是我不知道，
苹果风是不是对的，
但是,
从我个，
我本身就比较喜欢，
苹果风格，
我觉得苹果风格，
至少看的舒服，
而且,
这车给的，
感觉就，
有些人会说，
你这外观过于灯，
有些不会，
如何之类的，
但是,
在,
理想来，
有这个车上，
任何的形容词，
你又觉得，
这个车好看，
自然,
至少,
尤其对，
你看,
今年其实大部分的车型，
尤其是，
不要成功的车型，
基本上在外观，
都没有做大幅度的修改，
没错,
基本上外观，
都没有什么太大的修改，
直接的，
好处就在说，
脑用户，
可以继续，
难买以这个车，
或者是推荐朋友来买，
它不会有很明确的背刺感，
但是呢，
你又要在脑的车上，
变得更漂亮，
我觉得这是个非常难的难题，
你觉得我不能被背刺，
但是你车一定要比老车主，
感觉,
离开了，
问戒就很明显，
就是我要强调，
是我更霸气，
然后更豪华，
那问戒就给我感觉，
更简洁，
更自然一点，
而且两个风格，
其实我觉得都做得不错，
L9那个风格，
我觉得自然点，
就整个豪华，
高级感，
其实我觉得是比较很强，
所以我其实，
挺喜欢这个风格，
基本就这样，
但是你说，
变势度很强，
就没有，
就我觉得，
它是一个成功的，
改款车系，
如果从我个人感觉，
它说,
定一眼，
我觉得它就是个，
很成功的改款车系，
其他的没啥的。
我简单说一下，
我的感受，
因为刚才，
小康和肉呆，
都谈到了，
他的,
设计的情绪价值，
但他们对，
等于不等于有些，
不同的看法，
给我的感觉是，
包括之前看了，
李翔和纳加的对话也好，
还是纳加接受，
深度的访谈也好，
我觉得他们其实，
一直在，
强调的很多，
关于设计的，
背后的思考和原因，
先不说，
这个本身对不对，
或者说，
大家对他们的，
观点是不是认可，
我觉得他们，
有一个，
很好的做法，
是其他品牌，
很少能做到的，
他们,
在设计上，
不论是造型，
还是内饰，
他们的方法论是，
共性的提炼，
而不是说，
直接找班，
他们也会谈到说，
他们会从，
比如说，
宝马也好，
或者奔驰也好，
身上学习到，
什么样的东西，
但是他们，
会把它落造，
说,
我怎么来改善，
我造型的比例姿态，
我内饰的一些，
这种,
跟人感受，
能达到一些，
所谓的，
他们自己，
一个提炼的概念，
叫做,
奢华的松齿，
这就有点像，
当初,
乔布斯说过那个，
做什么好的，
艺术家，
以及,
伟大的艺术家，
嫖妾,
他那个steal，
是指,
他能够把，
一些好的东西，
用到自己的，
产品上，
而不是直接找班，
我觉得这个，
是理想，
让我看到，
他们的，
厉害的地方，
在内饰上，
特别是，
但另一方面，
我觉得，
他们在造型上，
但一说说法，
我不是很认可，
包括他们说，
之所以，
今天这个造型，
变了比利姿态，
但是,
为什么大家看起来很像呢，
因为,
这来自于，
这种,
豪华品牌，
要保持自己，
设计,
延续性的，
理念,
以及特权，
然后他们举个例子，
包括像，
鲁虎懒生，
奔驰的一些变化，
他们说这些，
豪华品牌，
都会在不同的，
代际上，
保留核心，
设计理念，
我觉得这个，
话逻辑，
没有问题，
但是,
这些,
好的产品，
让用户，
感受到了，
这种,
很多的变化，
这种新奇感，
同时保留了，
核心设计理念，
但对我来说，
而且,
Levis,
他的这种，
变化就非常小，
他这个举的例子，
和他这个，
这个,
这个论述，
我觉得，
中间是有一个gap的，
就是,
没有能够，
完全说服，
我觉得，
他们在造型上，
做的不像那时，
那么好，
以至于，
我小黑子，
就会理解成，
双色车身，
一个不足的，
一种弥补，
但同时，
这个弥补呢，
我觉得，
跟他整个的，
奢华的，
松弛的，
这种理念吧，
是有一定的冲突的，
他的内视，
比如说，
用肉单的话说，
比如说像木计，
但是,
双色车身，
是跟他有冲突的，
就是大家，
每个人的审美，
或者说，
偏好是不一样的，
对我来说，
双色车身，
是跟内视的风格，
不一致的，
它是更外显的，
更给别人来做的，
而它的内视，
是内脸的，
克制的，
高级,
是为自己做的，
但是,
我觉得，
就因为他们造型上，
没有找到更好的方式，
以至于，
需要用双色车身，
来提高，
整个,
造型方面的，
信度,
来匹配市场吧，
理想也卖出了半步嘛，
方向是毫而不登，
但是我觉得，
比如说，
百分之八十，
做到了毫而不登，
有百分之二十，
还是,
延续了，
传统华华的，
电视度很高的，
这种,
设计,
或者说，
卖点,
你们觉得呢，
关于,
理想的，
这种,
所谓的，
毫而不登，
以及,
什么是他，
奢华的，
松弛,
这标准究竟是什么，
因为它是一个，
非常非常虚的，
概念,
甚至说，
我觉得它是，
对自己，
设计理念的一个包装，
对吧,
它不是，
小高,
你先来聊聊，
因为,
我觉得，
我必须要，
在此刻，
坚决的，
站出来，
我作为一个，
L9,
Levis,
设计,
另外是，
都非常喜欢的人，
首先,
第一个是，
我,
我认为，
实际情况是反过来，
就是说，
奢华的，
松弛这个东西，
是理想的需求，
就无论今天，
Levis,
呈现了怎么样，
但我相信，
是,
先有这个需求，
出来,
也许,
理想今天满意，
或不满意，
依然做得不够，
什么之类的，
但主要，
我觉得是，
先有社会的松弛，
这么一个需求，
然后,
造型上，
我觉得，
近距离看，
我,
我认为是这样的，
就是说，
其实,
蓝圣也好，
WGM9也好,
这些车，
这时候一不换，
都是,
基于一个大北景市，
上代车型非常，
成功,
我认为，
有可能，
是有这样的考量的，
这里面，
假定的是WGM9，
是一个完整换代的车，
它不算中期改款，
我之所以，
这么说是，
从它的，
投资力度，
去包括车身，
白车身本身，
也在调整，
包括,
所有的配置层面的，
我认为，
它的,
迭代力度，
和,
二款的L9，
至于二款的L9，
这个换代力度，
是没有什么区别的，
所以,
我这么讲，
我认为，
L9,
唯一的差异，
就是,
L9,
曾经超级辉煌，
好了,
它的销量走，
是没那么好，
我认为，
这是唯一的差异，
那么,
如果它是，
一个马路上跑的，
很多的，
很常见的车，
很主流的车，
你就应该，
延续它，
我认为这个，
也是 make sense,。
但是,
我觉得，
这里边，
更重要的一点，
是什么？
这个方向上的，
迭代,
而不是，
完全重购一次，
的背景是，
比如像，
保满三系，
我举个例子，
如果保满三系，
油电并行，
同一套电，
那个被证明，
不太成功，
它就会，
选择像，
新的 i3,
那样的，
形态,
就它给大家，
一种,
幻然一心，
以至于，
外观造型，
本身,
的新鲜感，
成为一个，
触定单的，
一种,
一种因素，
一种可能性，
类似一种，
一种迭代策略，
那么,
在这个背景下，
我认为，
L9,
这种,
显然是在路虎，
M9,
这一边的，
然后,
这种渐进式迭代，
就是L9,
这种做法，
渐进式迭代的，
好处是什么呢？
它确确实是可以，
它确确实是，
更接近于，
一种,
从85分到，
99分的那种迭代，
由于你，
不会调整，
它的姿态和比例了，
或者说，
你,
依然再调整，
它的比例，
但是由于你不大改，
你是一个，
整体轮廓，
是非常接近的，
但是你的，
一个三年，
来去做这个车，
所以呢，
你有大，
大把的时间，
你可以让，
设计是把，
所有的大把的经历，
都去,
投到微调当中去，
所以这个车的，
实际的，
观感气质层面，
如果,
尤其新老，
新老L9,
放在一起，
我认为是，
提升幅度巨大的，
我认为这个是，
是OK的,
是成立的，
但是很简单，
我们再转过来讲，
假设,
Livis一败徒弟的话，
是不是，
依然要，
儀管他一败徒弟，
他的产品定位，
他的品牌定位，
肯定依然，
显然是一个，
豪华品牌，
那么他会不会，
去寻求，
保持设计的，
延续性呢，
我觉得不一定，
所以我认为，
不是豪华品牌，
要保持设计的，
延续性，
而是,
爆款车型，
要保持设计的，
延续性，
我认为是这样，
至于,
就是说，
是一个，
非常模糊的，
描述这些东西，
我觉得这个很简单，
那我觉得，
作为一个，
没有真正的，
见识过，
诸多别术，
因为理想在讲，
这个东西的时候，
包括发布会上，
在讲这个东西的时候，
他是以他，
有钱的哥们儿，
来举例的，
凡是装修的，
非常外显的，
会所风的，
KTV风的,
这些都没怎么住过，
放紧也就卖掉了，
凡是装，
装修的这种，
温馨的，
松弛的这种，
你发现大家都，
长期的去住那套房子，
那这里，
至少隐含了一个假设，
就是他那几个哥们儿，
同时拥有不止一套，
这种,
不论是大屏城，
无论是别墅，
所有这些东西，
那这个我没有，
这个生活经验，
我只能说，
只是,
车对车的这种对比，
我可以结束，
我以某种程度，
比较认同，
这是,
属于奢华的松弛的设定，
或者再粗暴一点讲呢，
其实我认为，
2022款的未来ET期，
我也是，
非常喜欢的，
我确实就是，
比较吃这一挂。
一个具体的问题啊，
你觉得，
拼色的车身，
属于,
车身的松弛吗？
这个我也要说一下，
这个,
我不觉得，
就是,
你上了双拼色，
它就,
就是,
我不觉得，
你要做一个，
克制的车，
或者你要做一个，
内敛的，
冷静的风格，
你就不能上双拼，
我认为。
当然,
这里边，
我首先先讲，
就是,
我是不喜欢，
理想的一些，
双拼车的，
做法的，
包括,
我不知道他们，
管理层也好，
就是,
就是那个，
L9的Ultra,。
也保留了一个，
紫色,
然后,
双拼车里面，
也有一个，
当然,
这可能只是个人偏好问题，
我是不觉得，
需要一个紫色的，
而且,
我觉得，
这个是，
和L9的设计风格，
是有点冲突的，
但是双拼本身，
我并不认为，
因为,
其实,
像,
Levis这次的，
这种双拼做法，
因为它不是沿着机盖去切的，
它是沿着机盖下方，
你去切，
然后,
要再加一条线，
这个的收益是什么呢？
就是,
它比较高级，
但是呢，
一个99%的，
大众消费群体，
包括L9,
本身的目标消费群体，
其实,
还没有进階到，
可以分辨这个，
高级的双拼车，
和没有那么高级的，
双拼,
车区做法的地步，
所以这个，
我认为，
尽管它，
这个饭就放在外面，
但是,
它依然是一个，
标准意义的，
肉满饭里的做法，
但是,
如果你告诉我啦，
如果你像，
老汤告诉我那样，
告诉了我，
这个双拼是什么样的，
然后,
我们的双拼怎么做的，
我当然可以，
马上理解，
OK,
你们这个双拼，
它确实是一个，
更好的双拼，
但是,
我认为，
就是,
即使是，
比如说，
金钟,
我最喜欢的那个，
金色和中色双拼，
放在那里，
放在这台车上，
我,
我并不觉得，
它是粗细的，
或者说，
是破坏了，
它整个，
设计试图营造的东西，
我,
我依然觉得是，
非常和谐的，
也是很高级的，
那么,
其实我认为，
这个车，
它就是非常高级，
非常有品质，
你一定要去说，
好,
有可能是刻板印象，
我觉得好就是，
奔驰,
那种方向，
我觉得这个车，
一点不奔驰，
来，有待，
聊聊,
设计,
收滑的松齿，
和豪而不登，
得罪人的话，
我来说，
有份件M9，
在前面，
你做成什么呢，
都不当，
就是这么简单，
咱还得客观标准，
那,
就是,
温家M9那个，
也不是别人，
轻易就能，
去模仿，
或者说去做的，
现在如果有个，
车企,
做出,
这就是为什么，
就是有一件事，
其实,
我不知道大家发现没有，
你,
现在路上的车，
做成L9的，
越来越多，
但做成温家M9的，
只有温家M9，
为什么，
那个灯味，
也不是说，
就是,
大家千万，
各位听众朋友也是，
灯味,
特别简单的设计，
你要设计成灯味，
不是说，
灯味和土是有区别的，
那土,
就是可能，
算了，不提品完名子了，
我因为这个节目，
被拉黑的似乎，
已经很多了，
如果我们把这个，
硬币的两端，
想象成这个，
为了,
比如做成为了，
和这个温家M9，
这是一个，
很清晰的一个界限，
然后理想L9是什么，
理想L9,
其实是属于家庭化的，
它是,
你比方说，
年轻家庭也喜欢，
这个,
可能,
中灯家庭也喜欢，
老灯家庭也喜欢，
它做了一个最大公约数，
我觉得，
它是做最大公约数，
这一代，
它加双清呢，
就是给最大公约数，
加了一个清凉油，
就是让大家觉得，
哦,
你看看，
就是L9,
还是那个L9，
人家稍微一遍，
你别的厂商，
是不是也要跟着抄呢，
我觉得，
它是把这个，
比较圈和人生立着，
我觉得，
只要实现这个，
理想说什么都行，
因为我个人，
我还是挺喜欢这个，
双拼色，
并且这个双拼色，
它不露，
就是,
我觉得，
最难得的是，
它一点都不露，
我其实，
很担心啊，
它,
工信部，
它给工信部的那些照片，
然后,
感觉就有点低估，
哎呀,
这个,
万一,
看上去，
你说这个，
对吧,
就不好吹啊，
这个,
你虽然，
它们不给钱嘛，
但你这个，
下不去嘴，
但是,
它们就是，
尤其是那天，
静态失价的时候，
它把老款儿旧，
传他们故意的，
把老款儿旧，
和新款儿旧放一块，
你发现，
就是,
不光是，
它的这个，
双拼,
上的变化，
它连车身的姿态，
和它整个的这个气势上，
你就会感觉，
旧款儿旧，
显得稍微有那么一点点，
现在显得有点小家的气了，
就是有点过于小家庭的感觉，
哎，这个，
你就能感觉是个，
哎,
最近这个家里，
升职了，
老公升职了，
媳妇升职了，
孩子升学了，
就是这种，
会给人这种感觉，
这种感觉你是说，
你会,
这种怎么说，
我想想，
家庭惊喜感，
或者就，
我用这个词儿吧，
家庭的惊喜感，
我升职啊，
或者说是，
这个老，
这个老婆升职啊，
或者说是，
又买到了一个新的什么东西啊，
我们换了新房子啊，
孩子升学，
这种家庭惊喜感，
能是,
这两摄像能够感受得到，
它和灯，
它是有很大区别的，
灯味是什么，
我走向了人生巅峰，
我现在需要用一辆车，
去彰显我现在的身份和地位，
我终于可以进入一个圈场，
它和那个灯味是，
不太一样的，
那种成功的灯，
那种巅峰和极致的灯，
也是一个非常难的事情，
但是像理想这种，
恰到好处，
能够引发最大，
公约数的共鸣，
能够让用户看到有惊喜感，
我觉得这是这次设计，
最最最大的亮点，
其实包括了内事，
包括内事，
虽然我现在，
我刚刚吐槽那么多，
刚刚我还脚进脑，
其实才想这么挂回，
这确实是，
这个给这个家庭的惊喜感，
就一家人看到这辆车的时候，
他的心情是愉悦的，
他觉得我得到了什么，
获得了什么，
我每次上车的时候，
有充足的仪式感，
这种仪式感，
也不是那种，
比较夸张的，
比较张扬的，
比较有张力的那种，
而且他只是，
就是我走到他旁边，
他欢迎我上车，
我上车之后，
所有我目之所及的地方，
都是新的，
都是有惊喜感的，
我开到大街上之后，
是有足够辨识度，
但是这个辨识度，
也不足够抢戏的，
只是让别人侧目，
让别人注意，
我可以为我的新车，
去增，去买一些，
而在思考去，
去显安，
我们一起做下的讨论，
给新车贴个什么样的膜，
给车里面买个什么样的东西，
这个是我觉得理想，
在L9 Leavis上面,。
体现了最大最大的价值，
就设计上带了最大价值。
还是具体一下，
你觉得双色，
跟他内饰的设计风格，
是一致的吗？
是一致的，
我认为是一致的，
只不过内饰的，
外观上面看起来比较克制，
内饰上的这个，
这个双拼或者说是，
这种设计理念，
稍微的过，
就是小康刚说的那个对，
就是那个氛围灯，
就是氛围灯是在你，
所有的复杂的设计上面，
给你拉一条线的，
就是氛围灯一辆，
所有的复杂的东西都会变得简约，
奔驰就是基于这种东西，
给你把这个，
虽然有很多人吐槽，
这个奔驰像夜店什么的，
夜店就是这样，
夜店那个灯一亮起来的时候，
什么卡座啊，
什么那些乱七八糟的东西，
基本都看不着了，
氛围灯的效果就是这样，
但是那个氛围灯弱的，
我就是那个，
如果说亮了，
你能自行的再亮一点吗？
已经最亮了，
大晚上啊，
就是看了那个感觉，
确实实实分一灯，
我不知道这个东西能不能购贴，
但是最好还是去解决一下这个问题，
因为这个一定会成为一个，
我觉得会成为，
至少是在互联网上，
会成为一个被攻击的一个点嘛。
少君，简单评价一下，
你觉得双色车身，
和它整个内饰的这种客制的风格，
是一致的吗？
第一个，
它本身这双色确实做得好，
做得很圆润，
过度啊之类的，
但是我觉得这些东西，
你讲给客户听，
因为我现在还在跟各家门店在聊啊，
今天晚上我们也在做会总，
他们的反馈就是说，
你跟客户讲这个线条，
就像刚才小康说实实说是很对的，
就是,
就阻不在乎，
哈哈哈哈，
你跟客家，
哇哇,
他们这个线条画的可，
他们漂亮了，
阻不在乎，
只是觉得这个线条真的挺漂亮，
就指定的双冰色，
确实挺高级的，
这高级在哪里呢，
我也不想特别追究，
因为它不是涉及到很，
严重体验的一个项目，
所以,
刚才还在跟门店在聊，
现在还在聊，
就是他们觉得这个东西很好，
整体的质感提升得很明显，
但你跟客户解释，
客户不讲挺，
客户觉得好看就行，
第二个的话，
就是这个级别，
你现在不上双冰色，
是不现实的，
因为大家都在算双冰色，
那双冰色，
我觉得有个好处在说，
它变质度特别高，
我今天刚提了台第19的，
银色侧顶的，
就是双色的那个绿色，
我们张志统计的时候，
双冰色的颜色也是最多的，
也是最多的，
不然大唐，
大唐的双冰色也是最多的，
只要买大尺寸的车，
双冰色整体看起来的质感，
就是比单色会强，
除非单色用户一定要买，
深黑色，
就只有买深黑色，
客户才会主动考虑说，
我要先买考虑它，
单色系的，
不然现在基本上，
客户对双色都是更喜欢的，
就跟老灯不老灯，
我觉得没有关系，
纯粹就是双冰色好看，
只是你能不把这双冰色，
做的不那么老灯而已，
或者是做的更加年轻化，
我觉得这是产家自己能力的问题，
所以双色这种东西属于，
用户觉得高级，
但是你跟客户解释客户可能不在，
用户就觉得好看，
但是一切东西就建立在说，
他肯定要先，肯定这台车，
他才会考虑后面这些东西，
确实这样。
那那些一线的小伙伴们，
对内侍，
这些来看车的人用户反馈怎么样，
因为之前内侍还是被吐槽的比较多，
就是其他的以前的理想产品，
说千年不变，
不论像之前的爱系列，
也是被吐槽的比较多，
这次终于迈出了一步，
大家能感受到所谓的这个奢华的松弛吗？
这种东西属于说产家形容词，
跟客户没什么关系，
所以产家可以拿来说，
爱你看我们这车做出奢华的松弛，
但是说是这么说，
但跟用户没有关系，
用户不会做出很明确的形容词，
就有个店，
你不可能指望用户到店之后，
看这车，
哇，我感觉好，他们松弛啊，
你想想那个画面得多鞋闻啊，
因为我只是感觉，
哎，这个高鞋感还不错，
他只会用一个不错，
就人不会有那么多具体的形容词，
他只是觉得这个外观可以不错，
但这次目前来看的话，
主要来自于，
目前绝大部分客户。
还是那个问题就是，
现在刚才那个，
是小看等豆袋说那个嘛，就是，
他现在很多好确实需要对比，
确实需要跟老款对比，
那目前跟老款对比，
对明显肯定是老款车组啊，
所以今天试驾的很多客户都是。
原来的理想有久的，
或者是理想其他系列的车组，
确实更多，
而且多很多很多，
感觉有点像之前未来ES8，
ES8也是很多老车组，
用户群体在复购，
觉得超值，
大家聊聊用户对这个，
那是外形的感受，
就是你们有没有一些沟通，
他们怎么来看待这次的这个变化？
这个其实和，
在最一开始，
他还没开发布会之前，
其实就已经发布微博，
这个也是比较让我感到惊讶的，
就是普通用户，
我们调研了，
就是想买的潜在用户，
和对理想，
就是无感的用户，
他们反而对外观，
和已经公布出来的内视，
还感觉还不错，
这个尤其是女性用户，
对他的青睐职会比较高，
这个当时也，
我记得咱们那次节目也说过，
其实就是，
你像这几个酒系，
那你要让这个家庭女性用户去选，
可能这个问戒M9，
是因为品牌的因素，
那个女性用户会选，
但是如果论设计来说，
女性用户首先，
可能觉得不太行，
那就是问戒，
那ES9的话，
是因为它过大，
这个东西大到一定程度，
女性用户就会觉得，
这是不是偏商务，
偏这种行政级的这种东西，
反而是它会，
让提升ES8的这个效率，
那到R9这边呢，
我们看，
我们现在也在看所有的这个，
用户的市价反馈，
我现在能够看到的这个用户反馈是，
简单说，
还没清醒完这些数据，
就是对于内视的变化，
接触程度还是比较高的，
没百位看知的用户，
大概有百分之七十左右，
是认可这一次，
内视的这些设计了，
觉得它，
就是如果用形容词，
去形容内视的变化，
我看和这种年纪比较大，
这种什么这个老灯的这种形式有，
肯定是有，
大概加起来占到百分之十几到二十几，
但是大多数还是感觉更像这个，
更像客厅，
更像一个，
这种家庭化设计的描述，
去描述这个内视，
外观的双屏色，
其实就是邵军刚刚说的，
它,
哪些电好，
越大的电源好，
旁边摆着，
这个i8,
L8的,
感觉这个车，
不过这个车，
还很好看，
有对语才行，
但是有那种电中电的那种，
就是应该现在电中电，
还没有这个，
还没有那个车，
所以电中电，
我们这些数据，
就目前还是空的，
就整体来说，
对于用户来说，
对这次R9Livis的这些变化，
还是比较认可的，
但是对于转化，
从实际销量来说，
目前我们能够看到的数据，
还是比一个处的，
一个比较低位的状态，
看着这个外观，
然后就是否增加了我这个，
购买的这个倾向呢，
肯定增加了，
但它不是决定性的因素，
还是要看它这个动态的这个感受，
外观不构成一个
绝对的一个影响因素，
目前目前的数据，
正好跟着延续追问一下，
对于R9Livis来说，
它有什么独特的卖点，
或者说功能配置能够，
在用户间，
可以去传播信，
它来看车，
甚至是购买决策，
因为当下你们它那些自己的感受，
在用户上的，
因为之前最开始第一代的时候，
我理解，
那当时冰彩沙，
确实是价值感非常的足，
甚至说冲击力很强，
大家口口相纯，
很容易盖得到这款产品的利益点在哪里，
那今天呢，
今天这个R9Livis。
有没有这样的东西，
还是说，
它仍然是像刚才，
就是理想自己也曾经说过，
自己的产品利益就是肉卖家犯例，
还是这样的状况吗？
它更新了剧多的配置啊。
现在看到的是，
其实用户能够吸引用户的，
其实是多是媒体的这些宣传，
因为现在，
距离整个用户所能，
试价的还是比较少量的用户，
这个资源有限，
然后呢，
用户对于这个的感受，
基本上来自于媒体和这个，
官方渠道宣传是比较多的，
用户觉得感觉比较大的，
就是它的底盘，
它开起来这个是什么感受，
以及它的这个，
我就接着往下说，
第一是底盘，
然后售价先不说，
第一名以外是售价，
往下就是底盘，
然后第三的话就是它的智能化，
就包括了它的做仓智能化，
以及它的价水智能化，
然后再往下的话，
就是它的内饰设计做起来怎么样，
然后这个整体的这个质感，
以及它的这个设计，
然后现在因为很多前段时间的，
这个各个场上的渔情，
安全性也是用户所关注的，
但是安全，
我说句话可能稍微有点得罪人，
安全在目前，
它不影响这个车的一个实际的销量，
只有在少部分，
车上会这样，
那是像理想啊，
问戒,
大家对它都是有这个安全认知的，
所以这个安全，
就其实是可以不算的在内的，
用户感知最强的就是底盘，
那个800伏，
包括现在这个用户，
我们得到用户反馈，
是它在小红书上，
在抖音，
在一些公众平台所能收到的信息，
也是在这个48伏和800伏在吵架，
尤其是视频号，
视频号对这个事情的影响是蛮大的，
就是用户会感知，
什么是800伏，
什么48伏，
也是给各大场上一个建议，
如果想快速的去铺这件事情，
视频号是个可以先去考虑的这个，
这个投放平台，
因为用户一分享，
销售一分享，
那这个用户首先能够看到永远是朋友圈，
那说偏了，
就是这个800伏的话，
它的底盘在门店的展示方式，
也决定了它对用户的这个吸引力，
它也是一个唯一能把肉先挑剥，
先剥在上面的这么一个方，
就是一个比较笨的一个方法，
但是比较有效的方法，
还是大概顺序就是这样，
但800伏怎么来信用户呢，
因为就像刚才说的，
用户其实也分不清800伏48伏，
就这东西究竟带来用户利益是什么的，
好开,
乘坐舒适，
用户很难盖得到，
这个主动选家的一些利益点，
普通用户，
这个就要说到理想，
这个在早期营销方式的一个错误，
它总是想，
利用自己的产品个性，
去转化为产品的好处，
然后去吸引51%的人，
但是800伏这件事情呢，
我觉得就是好就好在什么地方，
49%的想买，
49%的不想买，
而你要争的是那个中间的2%，
800伏就是争那个2%，
你只要把这个2%搞定就行，
那怎么去搞定这2%呢，
用极其怎么说夸张的方式，
或者说是比较有穴头的方式吸引他们，
转换到那个百分之，
就是想买的那个那个玻璃了，
那怎么转换呢，
就是其实就是你怎么对媒体，
你怎么就怎么对用户就行，
你媒体施加的时候，
那个底盘的那个欢迎来到这个时候，
不知道那两位肯定，
我不知道有没有这个邵俊跟小康有没有体验，
这网上也能看见，
就是他有一个呆帽掩饰，
这个剧烈的晃动，
杀停,
然后再加速，
然后他整个，
其实那个时候这个2%就一定会倾向到买，
接下来是什么，
咱们不可能光让用户去，
我们就是一个穴头，
然后在程序的试驾道路的设计，
也是很有帮助的，
在西南地区就不用说，
他这个上下坡啊，管弯啊，
你在北京，
你去一趟这个北京，
到处都是这种大，
大这个弧度的这种管弯，
这个上下扎到这些，
你这个道路设计极其不合理，
反人类，
感觉像三体人来北京设计的这个道路一样，
你要是体验一下，
他就能明白，
你在开的时候，
家人的感受是什么，
以及你的感受是什么，
这个是能去让这个2%也，
就完全夯实他们，
来到这个想买的这个区间，
很重要的一点，
然后这2%，
如果说在51%拿下了，
他们的MPS，
以及他们的用户反馈，
就会快速的形成适能，
这个速度，
要比i8和Mega，
能快七八倍，
这这个，
这个是我为这个结构负责，
完全可以量化，
这什么叫七八倍，
你以前七八个月，
才能让用户知道，
Oh my God,。
它原来是这样的事，
哦，i8其实还蛮好开的，
你现在可能用两三个月，
就可以完成，
甚至一两个月，
就可以完成的事情，
不知道有没有回答这个问题，
这就是我，
反正答案就是这样，
接着往下推进，
这次发布会也好，
包括产品的这个宣传也好，
其实给我一大的，
很印象深刻的地方，
就是家庭场景的变少，
包括这次，
整个发布会里面，
除了少数，
比如说，
妈妈坐在驾驶位，
给孩子敲两下出冰箱，
或者说敲两下，
打开后排瓶，
大多数其实就是，
抢掉,
刚才你们感受很抢的，
这种驾驶感，
它的一些新的芯片，
就是跟以前，
上一代，
或者说之前，
换新版的L9的传播，
巨大差别，
这是一个，
什么样的变化的，
当然,
包括李小四弟，
谈到了这次L9，
要做到越级，
这个是很少在，
之前,
只在i6上，
看到过这样的关键字，
就现在，
那L9Livis,。
它那么标人群，
是比之前在扩大吗，
还是说，
有新的一些用户群体，
就你的感受说，
这个变化大吗，
以及它的效果怎么样，
为什么要，
会发生这样的变化吧，
来，小康，
我理解越级，
可能很大的折断，
还是比如说，
后装可以改善它的，
消除,
就是魔法版，
消除它的大车感，
这是一个方面，
除此之外呢，
无论是，
转动旋减，
还是线控转向，
转向都给了，
这些做超本的工程，
是提供了更多的，
带宽,
相当于是，
能够让这个，
上线推得更极致，
就像在过去，
如果你要照顾，
全车人的感受，
你就势必，
会让它像船一样，
如果它已经像船了，
无论这个车上有多少人，
可能只有你一个人开，
你调到最运动，
最即日的模式，
它都一点不运动，
会有这样的问题，
其实我认为，
主动旋减，
当然,
这次加新加入的后轮，
像是一个，
也是一个新的，
我认为是，
对于架势性来说，
是比较重要的，
然后线控，
转向本身也是，
它至少是，
从数字化的角度，
提供了更大的带宽，
能够让你，
去把它的设定，
做得更丰富，
那么,
这些东西都有，
便于,
就是你最终，
能不能发挥的，
出来令说，
都是提供了这么一个，
平台,
提供了这么一个基础，
能够让这个车的性格，
变得更加的，
惯,
在不同的模式下，
就是更加的丰富，
就是你既可以，
就更加的分裂，
就是你既可以在，
你一个人的时候，
特别的运动，
也可以在，
多人出行的时候，
尽可能的去兼顾，
舒适,
我觉得这个是越急，
然后我觉得汽车市场，
无非就是这三类，
就是个人开，
然后家庭开，
以及商务开，
我虽然多次说，
这个车，
是没有那么浓的，
商务行政的，
但是大家设想一下，
如果一个人，
拿它来去，
做商务场合，
我觉得也，
也并不突，
没有什么，
不合理的地方，
这个大家能理解，
对，只是说，
什么呢，只是说，
就我们举个例子，
拿未来来举例子，
因为有ES8在前，
那么ES9,
可以在这个方向上，
显著走得更远，
比如说行政中档，
对吧,
比如说，
我可以让我的，
车头抬得更高，
哪怕在同款电池下，
对吧,
实际上ES9的，
选项表现，
是,
是当然，
它是不如ES8的，
但是,
这些设定，
都不是那么重要，
一切,
要让位于它的气场，
以及,
这种商务场合下，
这种,
这些,
这么一些场景，
设定,
如果大家是一个，
比如说，
我是一个家庭需求来的，
那没问题，
你选ES8就可以，
有什么不可以吗？
对,
我觉得，
是这样的，
那么,
L9,
我觉得，
你说,
它会扩大更多的人群吗？
我会觉得，
是的,
就是,
你适度的去弱化，
但是,
我跟余老师，
稍微一点不同，
反正,
我认为，
官方没有刻意的去说，
我就完全回避掉家庭，
就像你说的，
它这个，
官方的这些，
VCR里面,
我不是刻意回避，
我只是说，
我没有用尽权力，
说,
OK,
我们这个是，
一个为家庭造的车，
它是把这个车，
回避掉，
所以,
有点像是，
过去,
实在太左了，
现在,
它只是中立，
我们就已经觉得，
它变成右派，
是这种感觉，
我会觉得，
它这次是拉回来的，
同时,
它的产品的这个，
逻辑的角度，
包括它旗舰的，
这个定位的角度来讲呢，
我觉得，
它作为一个偏中的产品，
也是立得住的，
也就是说，
我觉得你一个人开，
或者是家庭，
或者是商务产品，
我觉得都OK，
这个角度，
我倒是觉得，
是OK的,
从它产品的逻辑的角度，
我觉得，
它是能够出达，
更广泛的人群的，
而且,
那我同意，
我同意，
就是说，
你要做到极致的话，
你就,
如果你要专注一家庭，
那么你就要舍掉，
那么一些人，
我同意，
这也是一个做法，
但是,
我觉得像L9，
这个级别的车，
你试图兼顾，
我觉得，
它是完全没有问题的，
在今天这个，
这个产品的前提下。
来，少军，
聊聊这个，
敌感吧，
韩家庭比，
没有以前那么高了，
更突出一些，
越级,
包括自己的价实，
等等,
这种变化，
对于理想L9，
扩大自己的市场，
扩大不了人群，
有帮助吗？
还是说，
它因为机盘已经，
足够稳了，
家庭不需要再去争取了，
就这么大空间，
吃得差不多了，
它需要勇敢的，
卖出一部，
获得更多的，
这个受众人群，
获得更多的销量。
其实我，
我没感受到必然，
必然的观念，
可能也是因为，
50万以上的，
级别用户群体，
确实不好，
单纯的打动嘛，
你看GEEK 9S,。
GEEK 9S,。
刚发布的时候，
是上海车站嘛，
就刚亮相的时候，
在上海车站，
我当时带着，
那天我就带了，
8P投资机构，
去看那个车，
应该是去年嘛，
去年上海车站，
我当时说，
这个车，
我说,
这次的车站，
因为当时确实好多车没出，
但是我当时说，
这个车站，
只要看这个车就行，
我们觉得，
这个车一定弄，
那,
其实证明后面，
这个车就是爆了，
那,
其实超级简单就是，
老板觉得，
这个车特别漂亮，
所有的老板都觉得，
当时我们，
看的话，
所有的门店都会反馈，
很多老板，
因为这个外观，
他就主动到店里问，
这车什么时候上，
而且他不在乎讲，
因为,
绝大部分客户来，
就当时我们，
有做快报嘛，
当时,
市场阵营不是特别大嘛，
就是我们说，
他订单是真的，
全网站，
我说,
有这个那个的，
但是,
这么做真的，
就我们缺乏出现好几次生意，
最后都证实的原因在于，
我们确实，
提前看到了一个东西，
就是,
举个例子，
就比如说，
极客9S,
我们看到，
你要清楚，
你的客户，
主要是来自哪里？
就不是说，
你自己觉得对不对，
而是你客来自哪里？
极客9S,
主要客来自哪里？
当时有百分之，
50以上的客户，
是直接来自路虎，
跟保时捷，
的出主增汉购，
那这部分用户买，
极客9S的原因，
超级简单，
就是,
我并不希望买一台，
特别老灯，
或是特别，
让别人一眼去看出来，
我好像有，
某个方面，
不是特别喜欢的点，
那,
比如说，
可能有些客户觉得，
M9太老气了，
对,
有些客户觉得，
LO9,
价格好像没有想像那么贵，
那,
我就酷依然，
高档感，
如何之类的，
诶,
客户觉得可以，
用户一下就能，
抓到说，
喜欢,
超级喜欢，
这在极客9S上就出现了，
所以当时门店，
就,
这车刚亮相的时候，
其实门店就已经迎来，
非常高的，
咨询量，
而且,
我们当时就一直在研究，
这咨询量的客户，
我们发现，
它的消费能力很强，
它确实愿意嘛，
所以不是说，
你想做了一，
我觉得Leavis这个车，
现在预线问题，
也是一样的，就是，
不是你觉得，
用户需要什么，
用户需要体验，
是这样的，
用户需要这个那个，
我觉得重点是，
50万以上用户，
到底想买什么，
为什么都会情绪价值，
而去买单，
问节目9，
为什么这么久，
到现在为止，
一直打不死，
就大家都说，
想要打死问节目9，
就是问节目9，
现在的量我觉得还行，
就已经说明周期，
已经这样子，
它依然在，
销量排行榜单也有排行3，
一个很简单的道理，
有个用户特别喜欢的点，
就是黄尾，
还有另一个喜欢的点就是，
它已经变成商务名片，
那,
这两个点，
所以用户产生一个购买的动机，
哎,
为了这两点，
我都得买一台，
就跟即刻9S一样，
我就因为喜欢这个外观，
我作为鹿湖宝石街，
我觉得这两个车，
可能新能源化，
没救了，
那我就想买一台，
平地,
但是我就喜欢这个外观，
我超级喜欢，
它就买，
L9的话,
我觉得它现在打法说，
哎,
就没有客户就说，
我就想拿这个车，
平时跑商务的时候，
然后,
每天都自己开，
自己舒服自己爽，
然后自己开过程中呢，
顺便兼顾一下家庭，
我觉得，
为什么50万以上都偏商务的，
核心点就是，
你想在你，
有钱能之间，
你寻找中灯，
或小灯，
我觉得是一个很幼稚的事情，
当年其实Mega有遇见这个问题，
当年Mega,
大家应该也印象，
Mega我们,
当年我借，
你们还借我们当年两Mega，
当时最大的问题就是，
需要车组，
需要当时想买车，
用户带着父母，
而出钱的人是父母，
来说服他们买一台Mega，
因为,
真的还是回到那叫，
中国真的有消费能力的，
人群,
就是老，
就是老灯，
这个事情，
如果你不能让老灯。
产生非常前代购买欲望，
他不会买单的，
今天我觉得L9，
为什么商务化，
为什么很多东西，
大家觉得，
不是特别老灯，
我估计他是想抓一群，
我想日常使用，
但是我又不想买的，
特别老气的，
一会车型的用，
至于有没有效，
我觉得可以再等一等，
至少目前的老车组，
是接受的，
我只能看到是老车组，
今天门店，
我现在在跟他们聊，
他们说，
百分八十的客户，
七十到八十的客户，
是来自老车组，
今天的事件，
证明老车组，
是可以接受，
他这种升级的，
那有没有更多新客户，
我觉得可以再等两天，
再看一看，
刚才少君，
你谈到了像，
问戒M9,
极客9X,
你觉得现在看，
比如L9,
Levis在,
整个这么多，
遍地酒戏里面，
他真正读他卖点，
是啥呢？
都在，你知道吗？
我就是没深刻研究，
我只是觉得，
不喜欢老灯的用户，
可能也是一个群体，
就不想让自己看起来，
老灯的车组，
可能也是一个，
比较大的群体，
从我个人感觉。
来，肉灾，
接着刚才，
一个是这个人群，
包括这次的体感，
不一定是真正的，
就是他的传播，
他的发布会，
在产品的，
这种市场传播上，
弱化了，
之前那么浓厚的，
百分比占比，
很高的家庭的场景，
突出了很多越几的，
包括主家的，
这种临终力，
李翔也谈了很多，
这种自己用车，
就这种变化，
还是刚才那个问题，
跟其他酒戏相比，
那L9Levis,。
对于用户来说，
究竟独特卖点，
是啥,
能够比较，
清晰直观的，
吸引用户的，
或者说让他能，
是什么，
谁，我是觉得，
就是李翔，
他只是换了个刷，
去说家庭，
我觉得邵军说那个，
对，就是他，
这关键性不是特别大，
大家基于对于，
李翔品牌的信任，
家庭化的故事，
其实是，
只要稍微换个刷就行，
大家还是知道，
李翔所有的这个设计，
功能的定义，
都是为了家庭展开的，
我觉得，
大家还是，
这些用户都是知道的，
面前第二很重要的问题，
就是说，
这是50万的，
现在的，
这是50万的车，
中国就是，
中国消费者，
就是全世界最，
怎么说，
最务实的消费者，
我花了这些钱了，
你就需要给我，
给我这些钱，
能给的东西，
那至于说，
你们厂商内卷，
那些什么，
那是你们的事情，
我消费者，
我给多少钱，
你花多少钱，
买多少功能，
那是我自己想，
享受的这种，
权益嘛，
然后呢，
现在50万的车，
都有什么，
你会发现，
林响R9,
Levis基本都有了，
很少,
除了那个，
这个EC,
LC玻璃啊，
这个路线的选择，
以外,
你看它能给的，
基本都给的，
有点像当年，
2020年,
那个林响R9那会儿，
就是,
你能想到的家庭，
和你没想不到的家庭功能，
我都给你放上去，
所以就是，
我觉得它，
回到第一个问题，
它还是服务于家庭，
但是现在的，
这个中国汽车的主要蓄势，
已经,
从家庭升级了，
就是我们去年的调研，
是觉得是小米，
推波助兰了一下，
很多年轻的家庭，
选择小米苏姬，
选择小米玉漆，
那都,
这个都是个，
你可以以前，
只有特斯拉有种待遇，
你现在看，
小米这个，
小米汽车这个品牌，
把这个家庭的概念，
重新又升华了一下，
就是,
你一个人也可以是一个家庭，
你和你的朋友也可以，
是一个family的这么一种定义，
你和你的宠物也可以，
你和你的女朋友也可以，
你和你男朋友也可以，
这无论是哪一种，
它都是家庭的定义，
和以前理想的那种，
这个比较窄的这种家庭定义，
它不一样了，
所以理想要适应这种新的变化，
i8和i6,
就没有吃到这一波红利，
或者说是，
他们做的还是不够彻底，
i6,
你已经明显能够感受出来，
它要提到越几，
提到那什么，
那可能是这一个车型，
所带来的变化，
但是R9Livis,。
它基本上就确定了，
这个理想这个品牌，
整体的这种家庭化的转向，
这种转向还包含一个，
就我说的回答第二个问题，
就是,
它的主要卖点是什么，
它的主要卖点仍就是家庭智能化，
它从第一代的，
2022年第一代R9，
一直到现在都是家庭智能化中心，
就是你的出行是，
人就是三个地方，
学校或者工作场所，
以及你在车上通勤时间，
就是咱们中国人，
不包括老外也是，
基本就在撒空间呆着，
那出行场景的智能化，
理想在2022年是有绝对化一圈的，
那现在它所销售的东西，
也应该是围绕这一点，
我们现在看到的反馈，
还是主要是，
你甭管是800幅也好，
或者怎么着也好，
它其实是，
大家要明白一件事情，
它是围绕这个马和M1板，
是展开的，
去围绕这个处理中心，
去展开的，
引线是什么的，
就是回到咱们刚一开始，
聊的那个巨声智能，
它可能在为，
你包括它的这个，
两个马和100芯片，
加起来是2056，
还是多少这个算力，
它就是R4的标准的这个，
一个算力基础，
这个理想在它那个，
跟老罗那个对它那边，
好像也提到过这件事情，
它在伯克里谈到的R4，
还是需要总算力要上万，
我觉得他不认为，
这代R9能够达到R4水平，
但是他认为，
接下来的几年内，
R3是很快能够成熟，
来落地上业化的，
对对对，R3，
R3我说错了，R3，
我总是，
被理想，
理想因为早去，
我言论说，
R3会很快跳过去，
我被它这个，
这个给逮不见了，
就是R3,
R3的话,
它是一个R3的一个标准的，
一个一个入门的算力，
到R4肯定到万级，
包括考研你的公司的，
这个就另说了，
所以我觉得，
它,
一切还是，
它的暗线，
还是为了这个巨声智能，
但是,
为什么我说，
这是暗线，
因为R4的时候，
才能真正的意味着，
巨声智能到万，
你现在这些机器人，
这些什么乱七八糟的东西，
我个人觉得，
还处在一个，
非常初级的一个阶段，
它解决不了，
它只能解决，
固定场景的固定需求，
它解决不了，
这个复杂场景的复杂需求，
这和手机完全不如，
这两个工具，
所以我觉得，
这是理想的一条暗线，
它需要给用户，
埋下一个，
一个种子吧，
就是,
你看我的马和100，
我像这个数据流的这种，
这种,
这个结构的购价的变化，
等等什么的，
它也是用这种暗线，
去吸引用户，
但至于这个暗线，
这个草蛇灰线，
这件事情，
能不能被用户盖得到，
那就是另外一回事，
因为,
它暗线，
这次是暗线，
是因为，
它对你的购买，
不形成任何的影响，
它只会对于品牌的构建，
以及未来技术路线，
形成影响，
所以,
真正能够产生，
这个影响力的，
还是处在明确的这个，
比较明显的这个，
主线位置，
也就是说，
你能够让用户，
感受到你的车，
开起来好看吗？
你能让用户，
感受到你的车，
看上去好看吗？
你能让你的车，
让你的用户，
感受到你的车，
坐起来，
是舒适的吗？
你能让你的用户，
感受到，
当你的屏幕前后的变化，
是因为你座里的变化，
你能让用户，
感受到吗？
用户现阶段，
对于AI,
对于巨生智能的理解，
也是处在一个比较触及的，
很多用户都会觉得，
你跟我一个AI对话，
像豆包那种，
那就是绝对最领先的AI产品，
它不会去想着说，
对巨生智能，
或者对于未来产品，
它们有一个真实的想象，
这个是没有的，
所以我觉得，
R9,
现在已经够好了，
R9 Levis,。
从产品力上讲，
我觉得已经够了，
剩下的就是看，
他们在手消气这个阶段，
怎么把自己的故事，
把自己的产品逻辑，
使用用户的地方发扬光大，
那就是800V，
这个线控，
你的座椅，
舒适度，
你的整个设计的这些变化，
包括你的开门的这种方式，
用户对于用户来说，
我只要看得见你的变化，
才行,
你只要让我感受到你的变化，
做上去，
确实和别的宇宙不同，
你再跟我说，
你讲你的故事，
讲你的未来，
讲你的案线，
我才能接受，
那否则的话，
我觉得就是，
你的米饭是不是，
放太多了，
你这个，
该太辞职了，
本来米饭就多，
你还按一按，
再往上再加点米饭，
我觉得这个，
对于用户来说，
就有点难了。
最后一话题啊，
巨生智能，
其实我对发布会期待，
跟刚才少君说的其实一样，
我特别想看，
他展示一些，
他们之前没有透露的，
巨生智能的功能，
其实之前，
我们在上期节目吧，
小康其实，
已经说过了，
就是不要对这方面，
可能有过高的期待，
但我老觉得，
理想会不会有什么，
大招,
最后能够露一下，
对我来说，
确实有点失望，
因为R9,
从一个家庭旗舰的，
一个定位，
官方的slogan，
变成了一个，
巨生智能旗舰，
它是一个，
整个公司代表位来方向的，
一个旗舰产品，
但是,
它没有能够说服我，
它为什么称得上，
巨生智能旗舰这个title。
小康先聊聊，
就是官方展示了，
啥巨生智能的功能呢？
来证明它是一个，
巨生智能的产品，
除了支架之外吧，
你觉得，
它能够，
符合巨生智能旗舰，
这样的称号吗？
李晓,
为什么坚持要用这么一个title？
它是一个营销的方式，
还是说，
它代表了，
其他的，
它的目的，
或者说，
其它的意图。
因为你发布会，
你已经把，
除了支架之外，
我觉得就没有什么可说的了。
几个例子吧，
因为可能刚才就是，
你刚才我说了，
除了支架，
就是对我来说，
之前,
它,
在谈巨生智能的时候，
是把很多，
它的配置和功能，
串在一起，
都用支架智能，
串在一起的，
包括它的主动全价，
就它的这种，
摇摆啊，
包括在车外，
云跟李晓同学交互啊，
其实,
它们都用，
巨生智能，
这个名字，
把它盖上了，
但是这并不能说服我啊，
但是,
就让我感觉到，
心里引有些，
觉得不好，
它们肯定是缺乏一个，
足以支撑，
巨生智能的这个，
这个功能配置，
以至于，
它们要把这么多，
已经现有的，
大家熟知的，
功能和配置，
放到巨生智能下面，
这对我来说，
是一个，
很不好的观感，
因为这些东西，
对我来说，
不是巨生智能，
当然,
严格意义上来说，
是,
但是,
它配不上，
说属一个，
旗舰上面的，
巨生智能的功能，
但是,
不论是预热，
甚至包括在，
发布会的视频里面，
其实很多东西，
都是用这些东西，
来衡限巨生智能的，
功能的，
我觉得可以这么说，
就今天，
无论有的品牌，
会给自己叫，
AI汽车,
或者叫，
巨生智能汽车，
我愿意，
都不是那么大，
但这是理想啊，
对,
巨生智能是理想嘛，
AI汽车是，
是小棚吧，
我的意思是，
这可是理想，
这家公司，
就是我对它的信任，
就是它，
把一个东西，
叫一个产品的名字，
我其实是有一个，
基本的信任的，
不不不，
我觉得我们就，
还是从技术角度，
去,
去分析这个事情，
就是汽车是，
装在轮子上的，
机器人，
或者是，
移动的机器人，
这个概念，
床,
我印象的就是，
2014年,
这个autopilot,。
还没上车，
但是很明显，
他们内部，
已经开始分析，
开始规划了，
OK,
也许未来，
可以用，
可以让车，
变得更质等，
可以,
可以逐步，
逐步,
让车变得，
变得开始自动驾驶，
我认为，
在那一刻，
这个事儿，
就已经，
终于营销而轻于实际的，
因为你并没有，
改变这个本质，
就是,
我认为，
一台车，
最大程度，
去体现它，
巨神智能的，
依然是自动驾驶，
那么,
你说,
8797也好,
或者说，
包括,
你想看是，
探索的一些，
多摩太的交互，
包括,
车内的摄像头，
车外的，
麦克风，
所有这些东西，
是不是能够，
超越自动驾驶，
或者说，
至少开出另一套来，
就是让，
自动驾驶，
是,
巨神智能内涵的，
50%降倒,
另外那些，
能够占到，
另外的50%呢，
是不是能呢，
我,
我目前是觉得，
非常悲观，
无论其他的，
传感器，
执行器，
计算平台，
挣到,
何种地步，
我依然都非常悲观，
我认为，
真正,
张显一台车，
代表巨神智能，
或者是代表一台车，
这些机器人属性呢，
我认为，
所以我就非常期待，
被打脸吧，
这里面，
突然以，
声音的插入的一句，
来自MIT导师的名言，
非常期待，
被打脸，
打脸,
就只能说这么多，
我觉得，
至于说，
自动驾驶本身，
没有拿出来，
更牛,
更炫的东西，
我认为，
就完全合理，
就是,
我之前的，
伯克里说的，
也是,
肉戴今天，
也刚刚前面说到的，
就是,
你要适配一个新的平台，
能够拉齐，
跟过往老平台，
同等的体验，
我觉得就非常牛了。
关于绝智能，
再补充一点，
在发布会之后的，
直播里面，
理想和，
老汤哥，
一起在说车的时候，
其实,
解释了一下，
绝智能，
他们强调了一点说，
这是一个起点，
意思是说，
我们现在是，
搭建了一个架构，
但是,
很多的功能，
现在还交付不了，
它现在可能，
只有百分之十，
解释说，
它是一个，
长期的，
方向,
以及,
它用另外一种说法，
说,
我们,
我们认为，
买L90VS的用户，
是用户，
而不是客户，
是一起来成长的，
但我觉得，
这个说法，
就有点，
不是让我很满意吧，
或者说，
他们,
是不是可以在，
发布会的本身，
对军智能，
有一定的解释，
就是,
哪怕是起点的，
你告诉我一个方向，
但是,
只有在，
这个非发布会的，
他们会有一些，
这样的说明，
就让我，
确实对，
一个车，
叫,
巨声智能，
起见,
有点失望，
来，肉呆，
没啥可说的，
挺好的，
我想跟大家说的是什么，
各位,
听众朋友们，
不要看现在，
大家,
对于,
巨声智能，
说的有多好，
我觉得这个时间，
至少在，
二零二八年之前，
不太可能，
跟,
听众朋友们，
在分享一个，
一个观点嘛，
巨声智能的，
难点不在于，
不在于智能，
智能化，
现在不是一个，
难体,
难在了，
它怎么巨声，
人车狗，
就是目前，
就是比较，
比较,
那个,
集中的这个，
巨声智能的，
集中体现嘛，
车先不说，
它是辅助，
辅助驾驶，
我觉得目前，
车,
去谈巨声智能，
最强强强强强，
最能感知的，
机器人和狗呢，
不可能，
我体验过这两个产品，
极差,
它差不差，
不在,
不在于，
它智能，
是不是，
是不是能做得好，
我叫它蹲起来，
然后拿个什么，
什么东西，
哎,
交个两三回，
它就会了，
难在什么地方，
它和我握手的时候，
它,
它妈就跟那个，
签金钉一样，
时间钻，
它要捡个什么东西，
就是那个手的，
那个灵活度，
大家都知道，
那个手的灵活度，
有的,
我理解，
人形这个，
肯定会非常遥远，
咱还是回到车上吧，
就是其实，
理想之间说了，
它对人和狗，
会觉得技术成熟，
非常遥远，
但在车上，
其实本身是有一些，
对它的期待，
还是这句话，
但是,
现在你觉得它叫，
这个,
是一个纯硬销的做法吗？
还是说，
它有没有更好的做法？
没有,
就很坚定的缝军，
其实我跟他说这么大堆，
其实就是想告诉大家一个结论，
绝身智能，
它是个统一的概念，
这个什么机器人，
需要到那个时候，
才能有一个具体化的场景，
你现在汽车也是，
因为所有绝身机器人，
或者绝身这个智能的前提，
是你汽车搞好R4，
是你最起码有，
上万级别tops算力的这个，
这个处理方式才行，
你现在在谈这个绝身智能，
我这不怕得罪老领导，
我还不怕得罪这个，
他完完全全是一个穴头，
他只能执行软件层面上的智能化，
你继身了吗？
那我觉得没有，
这绝身智能在车上，
就像马戏团那个感觉一样，
他只是秀，
他不会成为一个具体的，
这么一个形式战，
我的预判还是，
我不知道准不准言，
但我觉得还是2028年，
关键激烈，
如果2028年不行的话，
他就是2030年，
主要是我觉得这操作很迷，
就是具身智能这事对普通用户来说，
说实话也没啥说服力，
对吧，本身也都听不懂，
而且现在又是一个起点，
这很多功能也没有落实，
但是这么早给了这款车，
这样的一个定位，
一个slogan,。
我就觉得不是很满意吧，
OK,
没有其他问题了，
多谢大家，
今儿已经挺晚的了，
时间挺长的了，
拜拜,
咱们下期再聊，
拜拜小绝，
拜拜小康，
拜拜